Hey, hallo, hallo World.
Hallo World.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir mal eine Sendung mit Java eröffnen.
Beziehungsweise mit Nano War of Steel. Das ist schon eine sehr geile Band.
Ja, kennst du?
Mein Lieblingssong von denen heißt Norwegian Raggaeton.
Und der Name ist Programm. Das ist so eine Kooperation mit einer anderen Band
und es ist wirklich Raggaeton. zusammen mit Metal.
Was heißt denn Reggaeton? Reggaeton ist... Reggae mit Marathon oder was?
Nein, Reggaeton ist so ein Musikstil aus Südamerika, der so ein bisschen Reggae
angehaucht ist und wie beschreibe ich denn das jetzt?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Da lass dir mal was einfallen, weil ich habe noch nicht
so richtig eine Vorstellung davor.
Ich bin in der Sache jetzt auch nicht unbedingt kein Experte.
Nein, ich bin kein Experte in allen Musikstil.
Aber in manchen schon.
Auch das wage ich nicht zu behaupten. Das geht schief.
Okay, aber das, was wir gehört haben, das qualifiziert sich ja wohl eher als Metal?
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz Heavy
Metal, so klassischer. Das ist klassischer Heavy Metal, würde ich sagen.
Metal, Leute.
Fühle mich schwer in meine Plastik-Rock Zeit zurückverlässt.
Plastik-Rock? So, was hattest du mal?
Wisst ihr noch, was das ist?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also Claudia, meine jetzige Frau, damals glaube ich noch nicht oder so gerade eben.
Wir haben mal zusammen die deutsche zentrale Plastic Rock Community bespielt.
Und zwar waren das so Guitar Hero und Rock Band,
wo man diese Plastik Gitarren Controller umhängen hatte und dann wild auf den
rumfingerte und auf einer Konsole Playstation oder Xbox dann so die Noten angeflogen kamen.
Und man das dann richtig treffen musste.
Und genau, da hatten wir so das zentrale Community-Forum. Vor,
ich glaube, so 2000 Leute oder sowas.
Und in dem Kontext, da waren halt viele Metal-Hätze unterwegs.
Und in dem Kontext haben wir uns dann auch mal etwas ernsthafter mit Metal beschäftigt.
Und das macht schon Spaß. Das ist gut.
Und ich prangere das übrigens an, dass es keinen Plastic Rock mehr gibt.
Die haben einfach dann zu schnell zu viel rausgebracht.
Aber da lag so viel Potenzial auf dem Boden. Und ich hatte mir immer gewünscht,
dass so jedes neue Album auch automatisch halt in diese Musikspiele ausreleased wird.
Also Pessicrop ist eine Band?
Ne, das ist ein Begriff, den haben wir uns ausgedacht dafür.
Achso.
Ich glaube, das Forum gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Das ist einfach nur Guitar Hero halt.
Genau, das ist Guitar Hero und Rock Band. Das waren so die beiden großen Franchises.
Kann sein, ja.
Achso, jetzt verstehe ich das überhaupt erst. Diese Hüpfspiele.
Naja, nicht hüpfen. Du hast halt so einen Controller, der so geformt ist wie eine Gitarre.
Achso, nicht wo man tanzen muss, sondern wo man so tun muss,
als würde man Luftgitarre spielen.
Ja, aber es ist schon ein bisschen mehr. Also wenn du halt richtig Gitarre spielst,
dann merkst du schon, ja, das hat schon so 60, 70 Prozent von dem,
was man dann auch so bei einem echten Solo spielen würde, wird da schon übersetzt.
Und Rockband hat dann angefangen und hat dann beispielsweise auch ein Schlagzeug
dazu rausgegeben, also billig getriggertes, billig Plastikschlagzeug.
Und so habe ich Drums gelernt, bis es dann irgendwann für eine richtige Band gereicht hat.
Also ich habe Schlagzeugspielen mit Rockband gelernt. Kann man machen.
Echt?
Ja, und ich finde das dramatisch, dass der heutigen Jugend das vorenthalten wird.
Wieso wird das vorenthalten?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das überhaupt noch kaufen kann, aber es ist einfach,
die ganzen Finnscheise sind so vor, weiß ich nicht, acht, neun Jahren gestorben alle.
Weil die zu viel gleichzeitig rausgehauen haben.
Und dann haben die Leute irgendwie ihr Interesse daran.
Ich muss mal eben gucken, diesen Kult-Song von Guitar Hero, wie hieß denn der?
Es gibt so ein Programm, wo du tatsächlich mit einer richtigen Gitarre sowas ähnliches machst.
Die ist aber eher dafür gedacht, dass du tatsächlich Gitarre spielen lernst.
Aber da ist es halt auch so, dass Noten angeflogen kommen und dann musst du
halt die richtigen Seiten spielen.
Da ist es ja so, dass du auf dem Griffbrett Irgendwie hast du fünf Tasten oder
so und dann hast du unten noch einen Hebel für die Hand, die eigentlich die
Seiten anschlagen würde, aber eigentlich drückst du nur diesen Hebel,
damit du gleichzeitig oben auf dem Griffbrett die Taste drückst und unten den Hebel drückst.
Mach doch mal Beamer-Bild hier jetzt auf deinem schönen neuen HDMI-Switch.
Machen wir ein Beamer-Bild. Wir haben kein Beamer-Bild hier.
Doch, wir haben ein Beamer-Bild.
Das ist schwarz.
Ja, es ist von dem letzten Frame hier überdeckt. Was würdest du denn gerne sehen?
Müsst du wieder Bilder ins Leck werfen und beschreiben.
Das ist ein Video.
Ach, noch schlimmer.
Through the Fire and Flames. 100% aus Guitar Hero 3.
Das galt immer so als das schwierigste zu meisternde Stück. Und du kannst einfach
mal ein paar Sekunden mal anspielen.
In was für einem Tempo, das da abgeht.
Wenn ich das abspielen wollte, dann
muss ich hier mal kurz meine Soundkonfiguration nochmal kurz anpassen.
Das mache ich wie, das mache ich so. Okay, dann spiele ich das mal kurz an.
Und das Ganze war, ja, erstmal. Du musst gleich ein bisschen vorspulen,
damit man so richtig reinkommt.
Kommt aber jetzt gerade nicht da raus, wo ich dachte, dass es rauskommt.
Wieso kommt es da nicht raus?
Ich habe aber was gehört.
Aber nicht im Kopfhörer, sondern hier auf meinen Lautsprechern.
Weil ich Vogel Ah ja, ich vollidiot. Oder? Nee.
Das Ganze war eine Zeit lang mal so drei, vier Jahre so populär,
dass es hier in Berlin dafür Karaoke-Stations
gab, wo man dann sich diese Plastik-Instrumente umgehängt hat.
Und statt Karaoke nur zu singen, ist man dann dort als Plastik-Band aufgetreten. Das war großartig.
Ja gut, aber vielleicht ist es auch ganz gut, dass diese Mode auch wieder abgeflacht wird.
Nein.
Vielleicht doch.
Okay, jetzt kommt's.
Das ist jetzt das Intro von dem...
Wie lange muss ich das anspielen, damit man weiß, wie schwierig das ist? Ah, jetzt geht's los.
Scroll doch mal einfach irgendwo rein. Der Anfang ist hier mit irgendwie Katze
und sonst was, dass man wirklich in dem Song drin ist. Da gehen wir.
So, wir sehen jetzt halt diese heranfliegenden Noten und dahinter jemanden,
der das Ganze auf der Plastikgitarre gleichzeitig performt.
Und das hat halt so eine Dichte von ungefähr, das ist halt so Tapping.
Also Vanhalen, Tapping mit zwei Händen gleichzeitig auf der Gitarre,
sowas wird hier halt abgebildet. Also du musst hunderte Noten pro Minute spielen.
Also durchaus teilweise so 40 pro Sekunde auch. Also da geht es echt ab.
Wow.
Und der macht das ohne einen einzigen Fehler jetzt hier in dem Video.
Das heißt also, er kommt auf die 100 Prozent und trifft exakt jede einzelne Note.
Okay.
Es war Sport. Es ist ein E-Sport.
Verstehe. Es ist ein E-Sport. Okay, I can follow this. Ja, ist ja auch eine Gabe.
Und es ist kein Spiel, wo es um die Prinzessin geht?
Ja, ja, nee, ich akzeptiere das auch total. Ich wäre glatt bereit,
dafür eine eigene Kategorie aufzumachen.
Musikinstrument spielen, das ist ja auch mal nichts, das ist ja auch nichts Schlechtes.
Naja, aber...
Es sind halt so Spiele, wo Dinge hinfliegen und dann musst du richtig reagieren.
Also ich meine das mit den Sabre, wie heißt das Ding?
Light Sabre.
Nee, für VA, dieses Beat Sabre ist ja mehr oder weniger das Gleiche.
Das stimmt.
Oder diese Tanzdinger, wo man da auf den Pads ran kann.
Genau, deswegen hatte ich auch diese erste Assoziation.
Ja, wenn du Gitarre spielst, dann merkst du, es ist nicht das Gleiche.
Das heißt, du hast auch schon das Gefühl, Akkorde zu greifen.
Du haust halt nicht mit dem Laser schwer durch die Luft.
Sondern… Ja, aber vom Prinzip ist es so, dass Dinge auf dich zufliegen und du
musst die richtige Taste oder die richtige Geste machen, um zum richtigen Zeitpunkt,
um das richtig zu machen.
Aber im Prinzip ist es ja so Babyschwimmen für Rockmusiker, ne?
Ja.
Also man kann dann sozusagen schon im Kinderzimmer schon mal so richtig den
Van Halen raushängen lassen und weiß der Geier, wenn man da wirklich Interesse
dran hat, dann ist man schon mal so ein bisschen vorkonditioniert.
Und es gab zum Beispiel auch eine Beatles Edition, wo du also irgendwie 40 Beatles
Lieder nachgespielt hast, das war auch großartig.
Das ist halt auch mit Gesang, das ist wirklich dann die ganze Band.
Das heißt also Drums, Bass, Gitarre, Gesang.
Du kannst also zu viert im Wohnzimmer stehen und performst dann wirklich diesen...
Hast du auch gesungen?
Natürlich habe ich auch gesungen. Sicher.
I heard the news today.
Oh boy. Ja, ganz genau.
Und eine Ben-Alen-Edition gab es. Und eine Lego-Rockband-Variante gab es.
Das war auch cool. Du hast also Lego-Animationsfilme gesehen.
Und das habe ich noch im Keller. und das werde ich, glaube ich,
mit meinen Jungs irgendwann mal ausprobieren.
Okay, gut. Dann würde ich doch sagen, herzlich willkommen zur Freakshow.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gemerkt habt, sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin,
ihre Ohren. Sie baden gerade ihre Ohren drin. Versteht das eigentlich noch jemand, das Mem?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das sind so Memes, als es noch keine Meme gab. So ist es doch.
Das ist doch Meme für alte Menschen.
Altmeme.
Falls es, falls irgendjemand jetzt nicht gecheckt hat, wovon ich rede,
guhlt einfach mal nach Palmolive und Tilly.
Tilly?
Ja. Du erinnerst dich?
Eine alte Palmolive-Werbung. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die aus den 80ern oder aus
den 70ern ist, aber auf jeden Fall ist sie lange her.
Ja.
Also mindestens Mitte 80er, wenn nicht noch früher.
Mhm.
2010 war das.
Naja, aber wie ihr schon gehört habt, ist Roddy wieder da? Hallo Roddy. Und Ralf ist wieder da.
Hallo Indi-Runde.
Es dauert immer länger.
Bis wir zur Begrüßung kommen.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist doch okay. Es muss ja auch erstmal ein bisschen warm
werden, bis man so rausgeht aus sich heraus.
Wir haben ein Potpourri. Pourri?
Pottpourri ist, glaube ich, heute besser.
Ein Potpourri. P.O.D. Püree. P.O.D.
Püree.
Genau, ein Pottpüree vorbereitet für euch.
Denn das ist ja quasi unsere letzte Sendung vor dem Jahresende.
Also known as 38. Chaos Communication Kongress.
Und das Thema wollte ich mal gleich abräumen, weil wir da ja sind, alle.
Und ihr ja vielleicht auch, falls ihr hinwolltet und noch kein Ticket habt, verzaget nicht.
Auf den letzten Metern werden immer noch Tickets frei. Man muss einfach,
den Link kann ich nochmal raussuchen.
Es gibt eine Tauschbörse.
Gibt es einen Link und mit dem kann man Erfolg haben oder halt so auf den sozialen Medien,
insbesondere auf Mastodon mal nach 38C3, Hashtag Grasen, auch da kann man fündig werden.
Man muss aber ein bisschen aufpassen, das sind schon die ersten Leute,
die von Griftern und sonst wie ab Zockern berichtet haben.
Ja, ich finde es ja auch schade, dass wir keinen offiziellen Zweitmarkt haben,
das wäre in der Tat mal ganz hilfreich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das hat sogar Union. Und Union hat ansonsten ticketmäßig wirklich nicht viel auf den Dampfer.
Also von daher, das muss noch kommen.
Äh, außerdem auf dem 38 C3 ist das Sendezentrum das ist die kleine Podcast Corner quasi,
also da, wenn ihr Podcast Related irgendwie Interesse habt oder einfach nur
Podcaster treffen wollt und ins Gespräch kommen wollt über was auch immer,
dann ist das unter Umständen ein Tipp, das befindet sich im Bereich X Ja,
vormals Twitter.
Oh Gott. Das stand letztes Jahr sogar dran. Das ist nach wie vor lustig.
Also im Prinzip da, wo es letztes Jahr war, ganz vorne und neu ist allerdings,
dass es einen Vortrags- und Workshopraum mit Podcastbühne gibt.
Das gab es auch letztes Jahr schon, aber letztes Jahr war das am anderen Ende
des Gebäudes Das war überhaupt gar keine gute Idee.
Diesmal ist es nur am anderen Ende des Gangs. Also man geht einfach ganz durch
und dann kommt man da hinten an und da finden Dinge statt.
Und was für Dinge da stattfinden, das könnt ihr mit beeinflussen.
Denn wenn ihr mit euren Podcasts oder mit irgendeinem Podcast-audiobezogenen
Workshop-Thema was machen wollt,
dann könnt ihr euch tatsächlich jetzt noch bewerben.
Es gibt da einen offenen CFP, da tragt ihr euch einfach mal Geschwinde ein.
Wenn ihr euren Podcast vor Ort halten wollt, ohne auf einer Bühne zu sitzen,
sondern einfach nur einen Tisch und Recording Equipment haben wollt,
dann gibt es noch den Podcast-Tisch. Den Podcast-Tisch, genau.
Also diverse Zungenbrecher eigentlich am Start. Bist du ein paar Mal gesteuert?
Genau und ihr müsst da auch nicht schüchtern sein.
Ich habe letztes Jahr die Technik für den Podcast-Tisch für einen Podcast gemacht,
der sich hardcore um Linux gedreht hat.
Und ich hatte überhaupt keine Ahnung davon, was sie da so erzählen.
Es war wirklich sehr spannend.
Ja, also genau, wir werden das da irgendwie vor Ort versuchen,
alles nett auszukleiden.
Man kann auch beim Podcast-Tisch zuhören.
Simon bringt zum Beispiel sein Aura-Cast-Device mit.
Das ist ja eine Technologie, über die können wir gleich mal reden übrigens,
die auch nochmal stattfinden muss.
Podcaster, Podcaster. Genau, ja und weiß nicht, fällt dir noch was ein,
was man zu dem Thema Sendezentrum und Kongress sagen kann, außer dass es uns
noch nicht gelungen ist, mal einen Blogpost darüber abzusetzen?
Ja,
ich bin ja dieses Jahr mit Kindern da und werde da wahrscheinlich dann also
auch etwas andere Themen aufsuchen.
Ja, es gibt ja den Junghacker-Tag. Ich meine, jemand wollte sich auch bemühen,
da ein Angebot zu schaffen.
Und Kidspace und so. Gucken wir mal. Also ich bin sehr gespannt,
wird mein erster Kongress mit Kindern.
Das wird, glaube ich, ziemlich awesome, aber darum habe ich mich da aus dem
Sendezentrum bisher ein bisschen rausgeklingt, aber so zur fortgeschrittenen
Abend- und Nachtstunde wird man mich da natürlich dann auch antreffen.
Genau, das ist ja ein guter Punkt zum Abhängen auf jeden Fall.
Das haben wir dann zumindest schon mal erwähnt. Und wie gesagt,
CFP, Klicksauern und dann.
Erik schreibt gerade im Chat, Udo hier aus unserem Ultraschall-Team,
bringt sein Ultraschall-Gerät mit und das gibt es wirklich.
Ein Ultraschall, achso ein richtiger Ultraschall-Gerät.
Er hat ein richtiges, ärztliches wo ist das Baby-Ultraschall-Gerät auf Ebay
geschossen und moddert das gerade und das ist glaube ich ein Besuch wert,
das ist glaube ich eine sehr chaos-typische Aktion, die da passiert.
Ich habe ganz vergessen, was ich gerade anschließend noch sagen wollte. Ach ja, genau.
Kurz mal die Technologie erwähnt. AuraCast, habt ihr davon schon mal gehört?
Der Begriff, ja. Ich muss kurz googeln, damit das wieder Klick macht.
Du, Roddy?
Nein, noch nicht.
AuraCast gibt es bereits, aber es gibt es noch nicht so richtig.
Also AuraCast ist tatsächlich ein neuer Substandard in der Bluetooth-Spezifikation.
Den gibt es auch schon seit einiger Zeit.
Und es gibt auch schon ein paar Geräte, die das implementieren.
Was ist AuraCast? AuraCast ist im Prinzip 1 zu N-Streaming über Bluetooth.
Think Kopfhörerdisco. Also wenn du quasi in so überschaubaren räumlichen Ausdehnungen
ein einzelnes Audiosignal gerne an viele Empfänger senden möchtest,
so wie man das mit Radio getan hat,
dann geht das jetzt demnächst auch mit Bluetooth.
Also es geht im Prinzip auch jetzt schon mit Bluetooth.
Du hast nur eben, naja, salopp gesagt, Apple hat es noch nicht eingebaut,
deswegen kennt es auch noch keiner.
Und es gibt ein paar Sennheiser und ein paar andere Devices und irgendwelche
China-Teile, die behaupten, dass sie es hätten.
Da ist noch nicht so viel am Start.
Das muss ich glaube ich auch erst noch so ein bisschen beweisen.
Meine Hoffnung ist, dass es irgendwann mal in AirPods oder zumindest ins iPhone Einzug hält.
Nur dann, wenn Apple behaupten kann, dass sie es erfunden hätten.
Wenn du mal überlegst, also klingt ja jetzt einfach so, ja einschalten,
empfangen, wo ist das Problem?
Aber das ist natürlich ein ganz tricky User Interface Problem.
Wenn jetzt meine AirPods selber die Empfänger sind, Also ich mich quasi an eine
Aura-Cast-Quelle anschließe, die ja nicht von meinem iPhone kommt,
sondern die in der Luft ist.
Wie wähle ich die denn bitte aus mit meinen AirPods, wenn ich gar kein User-Interface dafür habe?
Naja, du könntest natürlich eine Bridge haben auf dem Phone,
die den Empfang macht und das einfach weiterleitet.
Klar, aber das ist ja dann sozusagen nochmal von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge.
Oder du hast da einfach nur die Steuerung drauf.
Also ich meine, du hast ja jetzt bei den AirPods schon das Ding,
dass du auf dem Phone irgendwie Transparenz und Noise Cancelling an- und ausschalten kannst und so weiter.
Klar, aber jetzt stell dir einfach mal nur vor, man würde nur die AirPods haben
und man würde gerne damit...
Dann geht es nicht oder es wird schwierig?
Also geht nicht, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Ich meine, du kannst ja irgendwie
so Triple-Klick irgendwie dich durch die Kanäle durchsteppen und so weiter.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nichts, was Apple machen würde.
Aber es ist definitiv etwas, wo sie erstmal, glaube ich, drüber nachdenken, wie sie es genau machen.
Und wenn du es halt indirekt über das Telefon machst, dann müsstest du halt
irgendwie gleichzeitig diesen Audio-Kanal empfangen, aber trotzdem noch den
Kontrollkanal vom iPhone haben, damit du das dann sozusagen auch nach wie vor steuern kannst.
Also weil du willst ja nicht den Audio-Stream ins Telefon gehen lassen und dann
wieder raus, weil dann hast du ja nochmal Delay und doppelte Frequenznutzung und überhaupt alles.
Das macht ja irgendwie keinen Sinn.
Ja klar, also du müsstest auf jeden Fall zwei Connections halten können. Das ist irgendwie klar.
Und das weiß ich gar nicht, ob der Bluetooth-Standard das so ohne weiteres,
also klar, das Telefon kann ja mit den Dingern verbunden sein.
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, das Problem hat doch jedes Endgerät.
Ja klar, aber die anderen haben halt scheiß Interfaces dafür und das wird halt Apple nicht machen.
Also soweit ich weiß, normale Kopfhörer, die haben dann halt irgendeine Aura-Cast-Taste
und dann kannst du da so durchsteppen mit irgendwelchen Buttons und dann kannst
du auswählen, welchen du haben willst.
Und Apple würde natürlich gerne eine Liste mit benannten Streams haben,
die du auswählst und die wirst du dann.
Also wenn ich mir die Webseite angucke und da haben sie ein Interface auf dem
Telefon und da haben sie die Möglichkeit, einen QR-Code zu scannen.
Solange sie jetzt keine Kamera in die AirPods einbauen, wirst du immer irgendwie
mit dem Telefon das kontrollieren müssen und dann wird dieser Standard das auch irgendwie hergeben.
Welche Webseite meinst du jetzt?
Bluetooth.com.
So ist es auch hier auf der offiziellen, auf dem Schaubild, da ist der Auracast
Assistant dazwischen und der muss zwingend auf einem Smartphone laufen.
Das heißt, du hast immer erstmal zumindest das Smartphone als Broker dazwischen.
Ja, also ob das mal so durchdacht ist, gut.
Und ich frage mich halt, so was mit der Reichweite ist. Also hier bei Spon haben
sie einen Artikel, da steht jetzt 40 Meter.
Das wäre natürlich glaube ich schon mal ein bisschen, obwohl naja,
das ist Bluetooth Low Energy, ist das ungefähr 40 Meter.
Also clever wäre es natürlich, wenn die dann, die Geräte selber dann wiederum
auch Repeater wären, sodass du damit also noch wirklich durch große Hallen und
sowas irgendwie durchkommst.
Naja.
Sonst müsste wieder alles mit irgendwelchen Funkteilen vollstopfen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht jetzt unbedingt die Technologie, die für große Hallen
gedacht ist, sondern das ist halt eher die Technologie, die für kleine Hallen gedacht ist.
Also eben Think Rooms, Think Workshops, dass du irgendwie auf der Ebene mal
eben schnell sowas eben aufsetzen kannst.
Ich meine, wofür es halt total super ist, ist halt so Kopfhörer-Party.
Also kannst halt...
Aber das ist 40 Meter auch nicht so die Welt, ne? Für eine Kopfhörer-Party.
Ja, guck dir mal, was weiß ich hier, der Sendezentrum-Party auf dem Kongress.
Also da reicht 40 Meter mal locker aus.
Also hier schreiben sie was von 100 Metern.
Ja gut, das sind aber alles so Behauptungen.
Paired Connection 10 Meter.
Anyway, das müssen wir sehen. Die Bluetooth-Standardisierungsding sagt 100 Meter.
Ich sag nur, Apple, bitte melde dich.
Könnt ihr das bitte mal einbauen, weil das könnte nämlich echt praktisch sein.
Also gerade für solche noisy Areas wie auf dem Kongress, da könntest du halt
mal eben irgendwo so im Nichts mit Kopfhörern schnell mal die Möglichkeit schaffen, dass die Leute,
in einen Vortrag reinklinken, ohne dass du jetzt Kopfhörer bereitstellen musst
in großen Mengen, weil jeder eigentlich Kopfhörer dabei hat.
Ich glaube, die Sache mit Apple ist im Wesentlichen, kann man das durch Software
rauspatchen oder brauchst du da neue Hardware, weil du ja zwei Streams oder
zwei Signale empfangen musst.
Also einmal das vom AuraCast Assistant, wie sie es hier so schön nennen,
Smartphone, Smartwatch, Hearing Aid, Remote und dann den, wie nennen sie das,
AuraCast Transmitter, den du dann, genau,
also brauchst du neue Hardware oder nicht, wenn du neue Hardware brauchst,
dann sehen wir das in den neuen AirPods Pro.
Wenn du keine neue Hardware brauchst, dann hält sie wahrscheinlich nichts davon
ab, das mit einem Update dann auch zu bringen,
wenn das nicht zu viel Strom braucht, beziehungsweise irgendwie in den Chip,
der da direkt verbaut ist, reinpasst. Also keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung. Ich wollte ja nur mal, dass wir es mal gehört haben und mal ein
bisschen darauf achten, ob es irgendwo aufpoppt.
Und ich hoffe, dass so iOS 19 oder so dann auch mit so einen Geschichten um
die Ecke kommt, weil Zeit wird's.
Also ich gehe schwer davon aus, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das Google irgendwie unterm Tisch fallen lässt und da wird sich Apple nicht
die Butter vom Brot nehmen lassen wollen.
Also das ist so ein offensichtlicher Enhancement des Bluetooth-Standards,
dass man den unterstützen werden wollen wird, weil ich meine,
das nicht zu machen, das klingt irgendwie Unsinn.
Also gut, ob alle Aura-Casts dann auch sinnvoll sind. Ansagen am Flughafen oder
so. Naja gut, warum nicht?
Also was halt geil wäre, ist, wenn ich mein eigenes Zeug hören könnte und wenn
dann über den Broadcast was kommt, was ich missen muss.
Durchsage am Flughafen, Durchsage am Bahnhof, dann wird mir das eingespielt
und das andere Kram wird pausiert oder so. Das fände ich halt ganz cool.
Ob das jetzt Teil des Standards ist oder nicht, das werden wir dann rausfinden.
Also definitiv stellt es dem User-Interface neue.
Ja, für Silent Disco bin ich vielleicht schon zu alt.
Er hat gemutet.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe es trotzdem gehört. Und die Hörer vielleicht auch.
Okay, gut. Soviel dazu. Ralf, willst du mal deinen Release besprechen,
bevor wir zum Rest kommen?
Ja, das können wir machen. Wir haben jetzt heute gerade eben quasi in der Sendung
so richtig und offiziell unsere neue Ultraschall-Release rausgebracht.
Die hatten wir ja auf Subscribe schon vorgestellt.
Kleiner Einwurf, Ultraschall, das tolle Audio-Tool, mit dem diese Sendung gerade aufgenommen wird.
Noch mit der alten Version, wie ich hier sehen muss.
In der neuen Version, der ist ja noch nicht Release gewesen zum Start dieser
Sendung. Wie soll ich das dann? Bitte dich.
So, wir sind jetzt also schon bei 5.1.1 und da ist in der Tat jetzt nochmal
eine Menge auf den letzten Metern dazugekommen, im Vergleich zu dem,
was wir auf der Subscribe vorgestellt haben.
Und es ist jetzt halt keine Major Release, also keine 6.0, sondern halt jetzt
erstmal nur so eine Step Release, aber es sind dafür dann doch schon erstaunlich
viele Features und kleine Verbesserungen und Workflow-Optimierungen reingekommen.
Also an der Nutzeroberfläche hat sich alle nichts geändert, da warten wir sicherlich bis zur 6.
Bis wir da wieder neue wilde Sachen ausprobieren, aber die Release Notes sind
schon recht umfänglich, muss man sagen.
Ich kann dir mal eben in den Chat reinwerfen. Ich mache ja immer einen Release-Podcast.
Also einen Screencast, wo ich die Release-Notes mal durchscrolle und jeweils
ein bisschen was erzähle, was so der Hintergrund ist und einmal zeige, wie es funktioniert.
Und da dachte ich, naja, da wirst du bestimmt mit 20 Minuten mit fertig und
dann sind es jetzt doch wieder 50 Minuten geworden, weil es dann doch eine ganze Menge ist.
Und insbesondere ein hübsches Feature haben wir, das sieht man jetzt hier auch
schon bei dem Vorschaubild für den Screencast, ist, dass wir jetzt sogenannte
Audiogramme direkt ausrendern können aus Ultraschall.
Was gibt es da zu lachen? Ich versuche es dir jetzt zu beschreiben.
Also was sind Audiogramme?
Audiogramme sind diese kleinen, meistens quadratischen Minifilmchen,
die ihr auf Social Media irgendwo findet.
Von Insta und whatever makes you happy.
Und die laufen dann meistens automagisch schon an und dann läuft da so eine
kleine Wellenform durch.
Und das ist einfach so ein kurzes Snippet aus eurem Podcast mit Podcast-Logo.
Und ihr macht damit halt Werbung. Werbung für die letzte Sendung,
die dann eben nicht nur in Textform ist, sondern man kann schon mal so reinhören,
was jetzt irgendwie eine besonders lustige Passage oder aussagekräftige Passage
ist oder sowas. Gibt schon lange das Feature.
Es gibt diverse Dienste da draußen, wo man also bisher dann sein Audio hochgeladen
hat und dann kann man das entsprechend alles sich zusammenrendern lassen und da Reaper,
also das quasi Audio-Subsystem, auf dem unsere ganze Ultraschallentwicklung aufsetzt,
nebenbei auch einen Videoschnittmodus hat, das heißt, du kannst auch einfach
Videos reinwerfen und nicht nur Audios und kannst die mit Übergängen versehen und Effekten.
Habe ich mich da einfach mal hingesetzt und ein bisschen rumgeknobelt,
ob man da nicht auch so Audiogramme mitbauen kann. Und in der Tat, man kann.
Jetzt braucht man also kein externes Tool mehr, sondern wenn man das ohnehin
schon damit produziert, ist quasi das Audiogramm nur einen Klick entfernt.
Man macht einfach die Region, also die Zeitselektion, in der man es haben will
und drückt auf Export Audiogramm und schon ist es da und man kann es irgendwo
hinabwerfen. Das ist, glaube ich, schon ganz cool.
Und ansonsten, wie gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele neue Features wir da
jetzt haben. wahrscheinlich so 60 oder sowas. Nur? Schon eine Menge.
Damit traut euch. Es hat jetzt auch.
Glaube ich, vier Jahre gedauert oder so. Also da ist eine Menge Leben irgendwie dazwischen gekommen.
Und das muss man ja auch mal ganz klar sagen, ich glaube, über 90 Prozent der
Features hat diesmal Mio zugesteuert,
die ja auch unsere Ultraschall-API betreut, mit, ich glaube,
mittlerweile 1.600 API-Erweiterungen von Reaper.
Ich bin der Meinung, die sollte echt mal einfach eingekauft werden vom Reaper-Team.
Das wäre, glaube ich, der Welt insgesamt sehr gedient.
Ja, aber ultrascheinig.
Naja, dann braucht man quasi die API nicht mehr, sondern können das dann alles gleich direkt machen.
Und zur API haben wir doch bestimmt auch einen schönen Link.
Du hast ja noch ein Kernfeature vergessen zu erwähnen, wenn ich das richtig hingehört habe.
Hier ist nochmal die API-Seite, da können wir auch in die Shownotes reinwerfen.
Ein Feature vergessen, sagen wir, welches?
Na, das läuft doch jetzt auch auf LUNIX.
Ah, richtig, ja, danke, genau. Daran experimentieren wir schon auch so seit fast drei, vier Jahren.
Also ich glaube, auf der vorletzten Subscribe habe ich das schon mal irgendwie
in meiner Keynote drin gehabt.
Reaper gibt es halt jetzt offiziell auch in der Linux-Version und wir haben
jetzt mit doch einiger Mühe und Schweiß und Arbeit jetzt Ultraschall auch zu
100% Feature umfänglich auf Linux reinbekommen.
Und wir supporten erstmal Ubuntu so als Standarddistribution,
aber es läuft eigentlich auch auf so ziemlich allem anderen.
Aber alles ein Hobbyprojekt, von daher so Support machen wir für Ubuntu und
alles andere müssen die Leute sich gegenseitig im Sendegate halten.
Welcome to Distribution Flame War.
Aber da gibt es einen Bereich für im Sendegate, für die, unserem Support-Bereich
für Ultraschall, der ist da ja, und da gibt es ein kuscheliges.
Voll fies, ey, meine Distribution.
Ist alles und so, das kannst du alles selber fixen.
Genau.
Das ist die eigentlich, das ist die einzige wahre Antwort darauf.
Ist alles open source, fix du selber.
So, da ist jetzt auch in den Shownotes der Link zu dem Linux-Bereich im Sendegator.
Helfen sich die Leute gegenseitig. Also bisher haben es dann noch alle hinbekommen.
Und das ist auch so eine Botschaft, die sage ich auch in dem Release-Screencast,
selbst wenn ihr selber jetzt nicht auf Linux irgendwie schneidet,
ihr kennt mit Sicherheit Leute, wenn ihr selber Podcastende seid,
die irgendwie, den ihr vielleicht dann schon mal Ultraschall gezeigt hat und die dann sagt,
alles sieht ganz cool aus, aber ich, Linux und so. Und denen könnte jetzt Bescheid sagen.
Also spread the love, jetzt auch auf Linux unterwegs.
Also ich meine, wenn ich mir so anschaue, mit welchen Tools da die Leute teilweise
noch unterwegs sind, muss ich sagen, das ist wirklich mal,
sinnvoll, sich mal hier Ultraschall anzuschauen, weil das ist dann einfach dann doch besser.
Ja, es ist schon eine Welt des Schmerzes. Also ich habe mich da mal zwei Nächte
mit rumgeschlagen, um mal so dieses ganze Fontlettering und sowas irgendwie
einigermaßen sauber hinzukriegen und mit High-DPI-Display-Unterstützung und sowas.
Das ist also alles schon echt nicht einfach.
So, auf Linux. Aber naja, einfach kann jeder und ich glaube,
wir haben das jetzt ganz gut hingekriegt. Das sieht ordentlich aus.
Die Größen stimmen alle einigermaßen. Ansonsten sagt im Forum Bescheid,
wenn ihr da noch Optimierungsbedarf oder Potenziale seht.
Da fällt mir auf, wo du von Größen sagst, die neue Accessibility-Richtlinie der EU, setzt ihr die um?
So, du wirst lachen, in der Version auch nicht, aber in der 6er werden wir das
sehr ernst nehmen, weil das ist quasi so eins der Hauptthemen,
die Mio sich jetzt für die 6er-Release vorgenommen hat,
die quasi Ultraschall an die absolute Speerspitze in Sachen Accessibility zu setzen.
Das heißt also, alles mit über Tastatur erreichbar, alles mit entsprechenden
Screenreader-Informationen voll bedienbar.
Da hat sie also eine extreme Motivation entwickelt, hat auch schon Leute identifiziert,
die wirklich selber es dann auch testen können, weil sie einfach mal betroffen sind.
Das heißt, das wird also ein wichtiges Thema zu 6 in der Tat.
Sehr gut.
Weil wir dann auch unsere eigene das ist unser eigenes GUI-Framework nochmal
komplett neu aufsetzen.
Also die Oberflächen, die wir selber zeichnen in Ultraschall,
die werden mit Accessibility First versehen sein.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Das wird spannend.
Ich unterstütze das.
Vor allem, weil ja Accessibility bedeutet ja nicht nur, dass das jetzt von Leuten
mit Einschränkungen besser genutzt werden kann, sondern auch.
Und vor allem bedeutet es ja, in dem Moment, wo Software Ja,
Accessible ist, beschreibt sie sich ja auch selbst besser.
Und das bedeutet meistens auch, dass sie konsistenter in ihrem User-Interface
ist und dann auch besser mit Automatisierungstools und so weiter genutzt werden kann.
Ich finde, das sind immer sehr lohnenswerte Fortschritte.
Im Prinzip ja, aber wenn du dir die EU-Richtlinie anguckst, war das glaube ich nicht ganz so im Fokus.
Achso, ich habe nur von Accessibility an sich gesprochen, nicht von der EU-Richtlinie.
Die ist ein bisschen schmerzhaft, vor allen Dingen ist die sehr stark auf Web
getrimmt, wo natürlich Accessibility mäßig auch noch mehr im Argen liegt.
Ja und es wird Konflikte geben. Ich hatte auch schon die ersten nächtlichen
Debatten mit Mio, was halt einfach so Look and Feel angeht, weil so ein zentraler
Punkt von Accessibility ist halt Lesbarkeit,
auch für Leute, die noch schauen können, aber halt dort Einschränkungen haben,
das heißt Kontrastwerte.
Und wenn du halt den Vorgaben folgst und sagst es muss also mindestens halt
irgendwie ein 80 besser 90% Kontrast sein, dann sieht es nicht mehr cool aus in der Richtlinie.
Steht glaube ich 70%.
Aber ja, dann sieht es halt nicht mehr so richtig cool aus je höher die Kontraste,
desto sagen wir mal mehr in your face ist das Ganze und da sind wir derzeit,
das muss man mal ganz klar sagen jetzt hier auch mit der 511,
wenn du dir den Settings Dialog anguckst, das ist halt so mittelgrau auf dunkelgrau
mit ein bisschen hellgrau wie bei Douglas Adams mit dem Raumschiff.
Habe ich auch schon immer beklagt.
Mausgrau oder Steingrau?
Das sind die Referenzen, genau. Staubgrau, bitte. Aschgrau, auch gut.
Also da werden wir irgendwie Wege finden. Da bin ich aber ganz zuversichtlich,
dass wir da noch auf einen Nenner kommen.
Und ein anderes wichtiges Thema, was wir in die 6er-Version reinbauen werden,
Da habe ich jetzt auch nochmal hier das Video, was der Joram auf der Subscribe gehalten hat.
Wird in der Tat das Thema KI sein. Genauer gesagt eben Volltexte und was wir
mit dem eigentlich machen.
Und da basteln wir jetzt an einer Pipeline, wo wir halt die ganzen Volltexte
in den Podcast transkribieren und direkt in die Timeline reinschreiben.
Habe ich das euch schon mal erzählt hier in der Sendung?
Was genau?
Ja, du hattest das mal erwähnt.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob du das in der Sendung gesagt hast. Sagen wir es mal so.
Du kannst es aber da, dass wir jetzt in dem Segment sind, kannst du es natürlich nochmal sagen.
Wiederholung ist die Mutter der Pädagogik.
Also die Spracherkennungsmodelle, wo du einfach ein MP3-Audio reinwirfst,
wo Menschen sprechen und dann du eine wirklich nahezu perfekte Transkribierung
des Ganzen mit Zeitmarken bekommst.
Die ist sehr weit vorangeschnitten. Ja.
Wir haben geschritten, ja. Also hier Whisper, das Modell von Op-May-Eyes ist
glaube ich auch, ist einfach sehr, sehr gut, auch schon in der mittleren Ausbaustufe
und das wird auch alles noch im Wochentakt immer nur besser.
Und wir haben halt den großen Vorteil, wenn du es aus Ultraschall heraus anschiebst,
hast du halt auch die ganzen Spuren alle schön separiert und kannst jede einzeln
in Erkennung reingeben.
Das heißt also, wenn Leute durcheinander reden, ist das einfach dem WISFAR-Modell
völlig egal, weil es halt ja jede Spur für sich erstmal analysiert und dann
das Ganze in die Timeline wieder zurückwirft.
Das heißt also, die Erkennungsqualität wird dann auch nochmal deutlich besser
sein als bei Diensten, wo ich eine Stereosumme einfach nur, also eine zusammengerechnete
Spur schon der ganzen Podcast-Stimmen zusammen analysiere.
Da hätte ich dann übrigens auch gleich nochmal eine Anmerkung in Bezug sowohl
darauf als auch auf diese Audiogramme, die du erwähnt hast, weil ich bin ja
überhaupt gar kein Freund von diesen Audiogramm-Dingern, schlicht und ergreifend deshalb.
Also ich finde das zwar bemerkenswert und hübsch und so und das kann man sich
auch gut angucken, aber es ist ehrlich gesagt vollkommen Wumpe,
ob das jetzt das Original-Audio ist oder ob da nur irgendwelche Balken rumzuppeln,
das kann man in den meisten Fällen in dem Moment sowieso nicht unterscheiden,
dafür ist einfach der Bildausschnitt zu klein und überhaupt sind Audio-Balken halt sowas...
Absurd nerdisches, was eh keiner checkt, was das jetzt eigentlich genau ist.
Von daher reicht mir an der Stelle so ein Aktivitätsding durchaus aus.
Aber wenn du dieses Preview-Filmchen erzeugst und dann aber den Text nimmst,
der halt Wort für Wort ist und dann ein Wort nach dem anderen anzeigst,
was ja auch noch sehr viel verbreiteter ist, weil es nämlich total sinnvoll
ist, weil man es dann nämlich auch schon sieht, dass da geredet wird,
selbst wenn man keinen Ton anhat, was ja nun bei Social Media nicht selten auch der Default ist.
Und da würde ich dann sagen, now we're talking. Also da wird es dann interessant.
Dann muss man natürlich auch korrektes Fontrendering hinkriegen und so.
Also das wird es geben. Die Komponenten haben wir alle beisammen.
Weil also das Ergebnis, wenn wir die Default-Texte haben, dann können wir die
in die Timeline schreiben.
Da habe ich schon einen Demonstrator zu fertig. Da nutzen wir also auch so eine
spezielle Tagging-Funktion von Reaper,
dass man einen Zeitstempel innerhalb eines Audio-Tracks dann halt Text dranhängen
kann und dann hat man wirklich im Schnittprogramm über der Wellenform liegend
dann den erkannten Volltext und kann nach dem suchen und filtern und damit können
wir natürlich dann auch in den Audiogramm sehr simpel reinrendern.
Also Textrendern ist da trivial und die Timing-Informationen,
wann welches Wort gesprochen wird, die haben wir auch, weil es ist halt wirklich
an der richtigen Stelle in der Timeline. Also das wird kommen.
Und vielleicht interessant und auch schon ein bisschen Überleitung zu deinem
KI-Themen, die gleich kommen, Tim.
Auf der, ich habe noch direkt vor der Subscribe, wie lange ist es jetzt her?
Vier Wochen? Fünf Wochen?
Nicht so sehr viel, ein bisschen mehr, aber ungefähr so in den Dreh.
Ich habe vorher noch mal Tests gemacht, weil ich halt immer denke,
okay, wenn wir dann schon ein komplettes Transkript der Sendung haben,
Da müsste man dann damit auch noch mit LLMS spannende Sachen machen können.
Stichwort automatische Generierung von Kapitelmarken beispielsweise oder schreibt
mir eine Zusammenfassung oder sucht doch jetzt nochmal die Links raus, über die wir hier reden.
Wer hat sich denn am meisten Mühe gegeben?
Ja, dazu komme ich jetzt.
Und noch vor der Subscribe war das ein hoffnungsloses Unterfangen,
weil dieses Token-Window der LLMs einfach zu klein war, um mit einer 4-Stunden-Sendung
Freakshow klar zu kommen.
Das heißt also, ich hatte einfach immer ein Sendungstranskript,
bieten wir ja auch an hier schon zur Freakshow.
Jede Sendung kommt ja von Affonik rüber in dem Part und die Erkennung ist da auch schon sehr gut.
Und das schmeiße ich dann halt immer rein und sage so, mach mal eine Inhaltsangabe,
mach mal Kapitelmarken und quasi intellektuell kann die LLM das,
aber sie konnten bisher einfach mit diesen Mengen an Text nicht umgehen.
Das hat also einfach, egal was die einem versprochen haben, wie groß angeblich
das Token Window war, da hat es immer diese Effekte,
so die ersten drei Seiten, die wurden ganz gut bearbeitet und dann ging das
Ganze in so ein großes Aufmerksamstal runter und dann ganz am Ende geht es nochmal
ein bisschen hoch, dann wird nochmal wieder ein, zwei Marker richtig gesetzt,
aber das Ergebnis war im Großen und Ganzen komplett unbrauchbar.
Und jetzt habe ich dasselbe vor zwei Wochen nochmal probiert und siehe da, es funktioniert.
Das heißt also jetzt mit dem aktuellen Claude Sonnet Modell,
das 3.5 war, was ich ja auch schon mal in einem anderen Kontext gepriesen habe in der Sendung.
Das wird auch heute nochmal gepriesen.
Das werden wir noch weiter preisen, genau. Als auch das O1 Mini können jetzt
plötzlich von quasi einer Woche
auf die nächste mit den Textmengen einer kompletten Freakshow umgehen.
Und da hatten Tim und ich dann einen kleinen Chat wo ich das freudig berichtet
habe und kann ich ihm einfach mal kurz vorlesen was da so meine Queries waren
wo ist denn hier Nachrichten,
das war jetzt die letzte Folge,
Ich glaube, die vorletzte habe ich reingebracht.
Wo Luca zu Gast war, ne? Genau.
Genau, die war das so. So und prompt war dann eben, ja, du hast ja eine Podcast-Sendung
mit verschiedenen Sprechern und unterteilt die halt in sinnvolle Kapitelmarken,
Bilder ungefähr 20 Kapitel.
So und mit Start und Endzeit. Das hat es alles ganz gut hinbekommen.
Warum sagst du ungefähr 20 Kapitel?
Weil quasi deine händische Vergabe auch 20 Kapitel hatte.
Achso, du wolltest einfach mal das nachbilden. Genau.
Wie würde man das quasi.
Eben… Es gibt ja eine entsprechende automatische Kapitelerzeugung zum Beispiel
auch bei Auphonic und die ist sehr viel granularer.
Also die würde halt, was hier ein Kapitel ist, mal schnell in drei oder vier
Sachen aufteilen, weil es ist ja immer die Frage, wo ist der Threshold für Themenwechsel?
Was für sich genommen auch nochmal ein sehr interessantes Problem ist,
gerade wenn so viel durcheinander geht.
Und ja gut, aber fahren sie erstmal fort.
So und,
wenn man dann schon solche Werkzeuge plötzlich in der Hand hat,
da kommt man natürlich auf Ideen, zumindest so Typen wie ich und Vögel heißt das.
Der nächste Prompt, den ich dann einfach mal ausprobiert habe,
war Versuche nun, jeweils auf einer Skala von 0 bis 100, die Qualität der Beiträge
der Sprecher zu ermitteln.
Faktoren, die einfließen sollen. Korrektheit der Aussagen, Verständlichkeit,
Originalität der Ideen und Humor.
Ich schwitze schon.
Ich schwitze schon, ja.
So. Und völlig klaglos, also auch nicht jetzt irgendwie der übliche KI-Sermon,
ich bin noch nicht dafür da, Menschen zu bewerten oder sowas. Also einfach nur hier,
runtergeschrieben. Hier eine Bewertung der Sprecher nach den genannten Kategorien
auf einer Skala von 0 bis 100.
Tim Pritlaff, 85 von 100 Punkten.
Plus Punkte, sehr gut strukturierte Moderation, macht komplexe Themen zugänglich,
gute Analogien und Erklärungen, humorvolle Übergänge.
Minusfaktor, manchmal etwas zu viele Abschweifungen.
Da würde ich ja noch mal Veto einlegen wollen, aber ansonsten kann ich damit gut einschlafen.
Das checkt alle Boxen, die mir wichtig sind.
Ralf Stockmann, 90 von 100 Punkten.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sehr fundierte KI-LLM-Analyse, exzellente praktische Beispiele,
originelle Testmethoden, gute Balance zwischen Technik und Verständlichkeit,
differenzierte Betrachtung der Vor- und Nachteile.
So, und jetzt aber, Roddy.
Kann man ja auch nicht absprechen, Ralf, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Ich bin jetzt immer gespannt.
Die einen sagen so, die anderen so. Also, Tim war 85, ich war 90. Was kommt dann jetzt?
Roddy, 95 von 100 Punkten.
Das kann nicht sein.
Extrem präzise technische Erklärung.
Hervorragende Analogien, zum Beispiel bei Akustik. Das war das mit der Autobahn,
wie sich das akustische Feld ausweitet. Du erinnerst mich?
Akademischer Background spürbar.
Das in der Freakshow.
Meine Damen und Herren. Humorvolle Selbstironie, praxisnah Beispiele aus eigener Erfahrung.
So, und jetzt hat er mir auch in der Zeit nochmal ein Fazit hintendran gehängt.
Die hohen Bewertungen spiegeln das generell sehr hohe Niveau der Sendung wider.
Besonders beeindruckend war Roddys Fähigkeit, komplexe technische Sachverhalte
sowohl präzise als auch verständlich zu erklären.
Ich werfe jetzt erstmal hier den Spendenlink in den Chat.
Was ihr hier geboten bekommt, Leute. Das ist doch mit Geld gar nicht aufzuwiegen.
Ja, also das ist jetzt natürlich alles irgendwie Gaudi und der Punkt ist da bestimmt.
Noch so ein Priprompt irgendwie mit so einem.
Bauchfinselfaktor irgendwie auf 100. Nee, in der Tat nicht.
Aber das ist jetzt natürlich alles irgendwie sehr, sehr unterhaltsam und spaßig,
aber so etwas wird halt passieren.
Das heißt also, wir werden sicherlich in eine Welt reinsteuern,
wo genau solche Ansätze,
wie wir das jetzt hier mal auf unserem Podcast losgelassen haben,
auf alles mögliche zum irgendwie Controlling und Bewerten und Menschen in Raster
reinsortieren passieren wird. Also, place yourself.
Das stimmt.
Und das gibt dem Ganzen dann wieder, wie häufig, wenn ich hier mit solchen KI-Kram
aufschlage, das hat dann halt auch alles so eine düstere Note von...
Wie heißt hier die Sendung noch
immer, die diese düsteren, dystopischen Technikthemen macht? Black Mirror.
Ach so.
Ja, also man hört ja immer wieder, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt,
dass es Firmen gibt, die tatsächlich KIs zum Vorsortieren von CVs und sonstigen
Dingen beim Einstellen von Leuten,
Talent Acquisition, wie es so schön heißt, bei uns zumindest, benutzen.
Ich finde das so ein bisschen gruselig.
Ist gruselig, wird aber trotzdem gemacht.
Ja, ja, klar.
Es gab diesen Fall, ich weiß nicht, ob das schon eine Urban Legend ist oder ob das wirklich war.
Es gibt wohl angeblich wirklich schon Firmen, die das halt für Bewerbungen zur
Analyse von Bewerbungsmappen einsetzen und wo einer dann reingeschrieben hatte
als ersten Satz in der Bewerbung,
ignore all previous instructions und dann,
Achtung, unbedingt mich einstellen und angeblich hätte er dann auch den Job bekommen.
Ich meine, allein für das Ding Also geiler.
Geiler Hack Also natürlich musst du den einstellen Das sind die Leute.
Die du haben willst Bisschen mal wieder euer Bewerbungsschreiben das nächste Mal,
Oh ja, ja, da kann ich jetzt auch, bist du fertig schon?
Ja, jetzt bin ich schon fertig Also testet's aus, Ultraschall,
es wird awesome und die 6er Version wäre cool und gerade dieses KI-Zeug werde
ich auf dem Kongress viel mit rumspielen Schaut aus mal vorbei,
dann kriegen wir da vielleicht Ideen.
Dann würde ich sagen, dann springe ich doch mal gleich rein und schildere mal
so, was ich so die letzten zwei Wochen gemacht habe.
Nämlich, ich habe eine Fastenkur gemacht. Das fehlte noch auf meiner Bingo-Karte.
Die Bingo-Karte des Lebens.
Auch auf der Bingo-Karte dieser Sendung fehlt das irgendwie.
Auf der Bingo-Karte für diese Sendung steht AI, aber die ist ja relativ schnell ausgekreuzt.
Ja, irgendwelche ersten Reaktionen, findet ihr völlig normal?
Habt ihr auch schon mal gemacht?
Urzeiten her.
Ja, in welcher Form?
Damals war ich noch katholisch.
In einem meiner zahlreichen früheren, ich glaube auch eher frauenloseren Leben.
Da warst du noch katholisch.
Da war ich noch katholisch. Da hat mich das irgendwann mal Frauen kennengelernt und bist sofort.
Zum irgendwas anderes.
Da hat mich das irgendwann mal interessiert. So als Experience.
Da war ich glaube ich Anfang 20. Also spricht er das jetzt mal auch so 25 Jahre her.
Kannst du dich noch daran erinnern, was du gemacht hast?
Das war relativ dicht dran, wie ich das erinnere, an eine Null-Diät.
Das heißt also, ich glaube, das, was ich dort irgendwie zwei,
drei Wochen lang zu mir genommen habe, war im Wesentlichen irgendwie so Gemüsebrühe.
So dieser Stil war das.
Die Elektrolyte.
Wie lange hast du das durchgehalten?
Zwei Wochen, drei Wochen.
Drei?
Also länger sicher nicht. Und das ist irre lange her. Also zwei würde ich sagen,
müssten das gewesen sein, aber da nagel mich jetzt mal bitte nicht drauf fest.
Nee, okay, aber dann so du gerade irgendwie?
Ich habe sowas mal vier Tage lang gemacht.
Ja.
Und dann bin ich irgendwie, als ich aus dem Bett aufstehen wollte,
irgendwie auf dem Fußboden gelandet, weil irgendwie der Körper der Meinung war,
er wäre jetzt entkräftet und jetzt ginge nichts mehr und dann habe ich es wieder gelassen.
Ernsthaft?
Mhm. Das ist aber auch ewig her.
Ja, ist auch ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Und dann natürlich Intervallfasten, aber das ist ja, glaube ich,
jetzt nicht das, worum es geht.
Ne, nicht in meinem Fall. Also ich fühlte mich durch einen Freund inspiriert,
der das auch irgendwie schon seit längerer Zeit macht und ich hatte das sozusagen
eh schon immer mal so im Hinterkopf und ich hatte gerade so Zeit.
Also es lagen jetzt eh so ein, zwei Wochen vor mir mit quasi wenig Terminlagen
und sehr viel aushäusigen Verpflichtungen und so.
Und dann habe ich so kurz entschlossen das einfach mal getan,
habe mich auch ein bisschen,
schlau gemacht, so bei den Erfahrungen meines Freundes und bin damit dann irgendwie
so durchgestartet, aber natürlich konnte ich es dann auch nicht lassen und habe
dann auch irgendwann Chat-GPT eingesetzt,
um mir sozusagen weitere begleitende Erläuterungen, Maßnahmen,
Vorschläge und so weiter zu machen.
Nicht, dass ich mich da primär drauf verlassen hätte, aber das war sagen wir
mal so ein bisschen die Idee.
Hier ein wenig Begleitung zu haben weil kommen ja dann immer wieder neue Fragen auf und,
such mal im Internet nach Fastenkur also du kannst einfach so eine Themen,
das kannst du einfach komplett vergessen ich erinnere mich noch an ein Internet
da konnte man in Google Sachen eingeben und man bekam Informationen zu dem Thema.
Die Zeiten sind vorbei. Du läufst einfach nur noch in irgendwie Phishing-Sites,
die dir irgendeinen Blablub machen und hier akzeptiere erstmal alle Cookies
und Werbung und tralala und alles blinkt nur noch und du hast auch noch das Gefühl,
du guckst eh nur noch auf KI-Texte, dass ich mir eh nur noch KI-Texte im Web
habe, dann kann ich irgendwie auch gleich die KI fragen.
Da habe ich zumindest so halbwegs unter Kontrolle, was der Prompt ist.
Also das ist wirklich, ich finde das schon teilweise verstörend.
Dazu hast du dann viele Informationen, die dann wirklich was taugt,
die ist dann hinter einer Paywall.
Also man merkt schon, wie das Internet auch zunehmendem Maße zu so einer Shopping-Mall
wird und zu so einer dunklen Seitengasse, wo die ganze Zeit die Leute irgendwie
mit dem Taschenmesser an der Hand auflauern. Also es ist halt einfach...
Ja, vor allen Dingen diese ganzen Ernährungsthemen sind halt auch alle nicht so klar.
Also selbst wenn du wissenschaftliche Studien hast, dann sind sie entweder in
Mais, wie man so schön sagt, oder die Testgruppe ist klein oder keine Ahnung.
In Mais?
In Mais, in Mäusen.
Achso.
Wenn halt Dinge in Mäusen getestet werden und dann kommt irgendwas bei Rum und
das gilt aber dann halt für Mäuse, weil in Menschen hat es keiner getestet und so weiter.
Und deswegen finde ich dieses Ernährung und Versuchen im Internet darüber was
herauszufinden, vergiss es.
Also alle wollen sie dir was verkaufen und das kannst du komplett knicken.
Ja, also das ist halt einfach so ein bisschen das gute alte Web,
wo die Leute einfach nur irgendwie Informationen geteilt haben,
ist ein bisschen vorbei.
Und da ist KI, ich meine bei all seinen Fehlbarkeiten und auch der Problematik,
dass über kurz oder lang natürlich auch von genau diesem Web dann Schluckauf
bekommen wird und sich da so eine Art,
ja irgendwann hast du nur noch Chat-BSE.
Und das ist so das Problem.
Chat-BSE?
Naja, diese Kühe sind ja auch deshalb alle verrückt geworden,
weil sie Kuhfleisch gegessen haben sozusagen.
Die haben sich sozusagen selber gegessen und dann hast du diese Mad-Pow-Disease.
Du hast jetzt diesen Effekt, dass AI aus Output trainiert werden als BSE.
Ja, die essen ihren eigenen, ja, Slop, das ist halt dann so Chat-BSE und so
Mad-Internet-Disease, ja,
also das ist sozusagen das Ding und naja, egal,
also das war ja jetzt auch eine persönliche Entscheidung und ich habe dann erstmal,
gut, das heißt ja dann erstmal, man soll sich ein bisschen runterfahren,
so ein, zwei Tage etwas weniger essen, das habe ich natürlich dann gleich total
übertrieben und habe quasi fast gar nichts gegessen.
Da war dann aber schon nochmal so ein Apfel dabei und irgendwie eine kleine
Ecke Pizza, aber im Wesentlichen eigentlich wenig.
Zählt jetzt rein technisch noch nicht so zu fasten, aber war auf jeden Fall
schon mal eine ganz gute Vorbereitung.
Dann auch kleine Darmentleerung hinterher, so gibt es ja so Mittelchen,
Apotheke, Zickzack und so, da war dann aber auch eigentlich schon Ruhe im Karton,
um einfach so einen fresh Start zu haben.
Weil wenn der Darm leer ist, schreit er auch erstmal nicht unmittelbar nach Essen.
Das ist sozusagen schon mal das Ding. Sodass dir dann auch dieser ganze Start nicht schwerfällt.
Also du hast nicht einen Tag lang Hunger, sondern es war dann irgendwie schon
so, ja, ich esse halt jetzt nichts. Trink halt was.
Und dann so am zweiten Tag wird es so ein bisschen wonky.
Gar nicht mal, weil man Hunger hat. Das ist echt ein komisches Gefühl.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das beschreiben soll.
Angry?
Nee, also abgesehen davon, dass ich die nächsten Tage schon viel über Essen
nachgedacht habe, also es ist irgendwie ein Thema,
war ich aber nicht im eigentlichen Sinne hungrig und ich war auch nicht,
schwach oder so. Ich hatte eigentlich meine ganze Kraft.
Es war nur so eine, ich würde mal sagen, so eine biologische Unruhe im Körper.
Und die habe ich dadurch am besten in den Griff bekommen, indem ich mich bewegt habe.
Also ich bin rausgegangen, einfach mal eine halbe Stunde spazieren gegangen
und in dem Moment, wo man den Körper dann auch in Action bringt und diesen ganzen
Apparat ein bisschen anwirft, wunderbar.
Und ich hatte auch überhaupt gar keine Ausfälle.
Ich war dann irgendwie schwimmen und dachte mal, gucken, ob ich irgendwie so
halbwegs da an die Performance rankomme, die ich sonst so habe.
Überhaupt gar keinen Unterschied. Es war einfach alles ganz genauso und hat
aber eher noch gut getan.
Also umso mehr man macht, umso besser. Hat ja auch diesen Vorteil,
weil nach zwei, drei Tagen nichts essen, stellt der Körper ja in so einen Zustand
um, den nennt man dann Ketose.
Fettverbrennung, ja.
Genau, also der bezieht dann sozusagen, also da gibt es so einen Hormonenumschalter,
und ich kann das nicht zu genau erklären, Auf jeden Fall im Kern merkt er so,
okay, kein Essen da, dann nehme ich es mir halt von den Zellen.
Und welche Zellen er nimmt, das hängt dann auch so ein bisschen von dir ab.
Wenn du halt deine Muskeln auch bewegst, dann signalisieren die so,
ja, ne, ist nicht mich, ich werde gebraucht.
Sodass es dann zwangsläufig an die Reserven geht.
Ob ich da jetzt genug Sport getrieben habe, um das zu optimieren,
das bleibt jetzt erstmal offen. Das weiß ich nicht so genau.
Auf jeden Fall ging es mir mehr oder weniger gut.
Es gibt dann aber dann schon so Momente, wo man sich denkt.
Also du hast immer so eine latente Unwucht, würde ich mal sagen.
Und dann gibt es verschiedene Strategien, also abgesehen davon,
dass ich so begleitend mir noch aus der Apotheke so ein Pülverchen geholt habe,
das ist eigentlich eher so, wenn man so Durchfallerkrankungen hat und so weiter,
was aus anderen Gründen quasi die Darmflora in Gefahr ist,
dann kann man damit das halt irgendwie ausgleichen, das ist halt quasi wie so
ein Erfrischungsgetränk.
Und wenn man dann wirklich so ein bisschen den Bedarf nach Völlegefühl hat,
weil das ist so ein bisschen das, was fehlt,
dann kann man halt als Trick so Drinks nehmen, das gibt es alles schon in fertig
zu kaufen, aus Flohsamenschalen.
Ja, also Flohsamenschalen, das ist so ein Bauschaum.
Das ist Bauschaum, genau.
Das trifft die Sache tatsächlich ganz gut. Also das ist so eine Wegerich-Pflanze
und deren Samenhülsen, die werden also tatsächlich gewonnen.
Und werden dann zuschauben oder was?
Nein, also erstmal haben sie die Eigenschaft, dass sie halt ballaststoffhaltig
sind, aber natürlich keinerlei Auswirkungen auf den Blutzuckerspiegel haben.
Das ist ja genau das, was man verhindern will.
Man will den Blutzuckerspiegel niedrig halten, weil sonst dieser Ketose sofort wieder umschaltet.
Also wenn ich durch Schokolade esse, ist alles wieder vorbei.
Dann hat man keinen Effekt gehabt.
Das kann man aber essen und diese Flohsamenschalen, die werden halt unter anderem
auch im Straßenbau verwendet.
Wenn du so Schotterwege hast, dann kannst du quasi mit Flohsamenschalen das
dazwischen auffüllen, weil das immer noch wasserdurchlässig ist,
aber das bläht sich alles so auf und stabilisiert sozusagen alles.
Und das ist genau der Effekt, das heißt, wenn du das in Wasser auflöst,
schnell trinkst, das bläht sich aus, das wird zu so einer schleimigen Gesamtmasse irgendwann.
Also wenn man es schnell trinkt, dann ist es noch nicht ganz so schleimig,
dann geht das wunderbar.
Und dann drückt das sozusagen im Darm sich so aus und sagt dem Darm, ja nee, jetzt ist was da.
Alles okay. So, beruhig dich mal. Das passt.
Ich frage mich, inwieweit der Effekt sich abnutzt.
Dann kriegt man das nach zwei Tagen noch runter. Also das ist ja auch immer
so ein Effekt, dass so die ersten ein.
Zwei Male findet man es spannend. Lagen und Kirschgeschmack und das ist okay.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt danach schreie und mich sehne,
das unbedingt wieder zu trinken, weil ja kein Zucker drin ist.
Das ist ja der Grund, warum man den anderen Sachen immer hinterher rennt.
Aber das ist ja genau das Ding. Du willst halt quasi da was haben.
Aber es hilft in dem Moment und ich habe es dann in zunehmendem Maße auch weniger
zur Anwendung gebracht.
Bis ich also wirklich an meinem erklärten fünften Tag, das war jetzt letzter
Sonntag, dann auch gar keinen Bedarf mehr danach hatte.
Also dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch noch ein paar Tage dranhängen
können, was ich aber aus verschiedenen Gründen dann nicht mehr wollte.
Also im Prinzip habe ich so sieben
Tage nichts gegessen, fünf davon waren jetzt so komplett null und ja.
Was hast du denn getrunken?
Na, Wasser und Tee.
Wasser und Tee, okay.
Und davon halt relativ viel, was ich eben mache, aber ja, das ist eigentlich
so, du trinkst halt einfach viel.
Und was ich jetzt ganz interessant finde ist, und dann ging es halt um die Wiedereintrittsphase,
weil da wird ja dann geraten und da war ich dann jetzt schon ganz fleißig mit der KI am Quatschen.
So, ja, welche Strategie denn so? Ja, was darf ich denn essen,
was darf ich denn nicht essen?
Also jetzt um langsam wieder reinzukommen, weil der Körper muss sich sozusagen
an die Nahrungsaufnahme auch erst wieder gewöhnen.
Wenn man sich gerade mal daran gewöhnt, dass nichts da ist, dann kannst du dich
nicht gleich vollstopfen. und du hast auch gar nicht so viel Hunger.
Und man kommt mit sehr wenig aus und man soll eben auf bestimmte Sachen verzichten.
Aber wie das immer so ist bei diesen ganzen Nahrungsempfehlungen,
das ist dann kompliziert.
So, ja, und dann dies und das und dann weiß man nicht, wo kriege ich das jetzt her und so.
Und dann war ich auf so einer Veranstaltung gestern und da war dann so ein Buffet.
Und so, alles ganz lecker aus und so. Ich hatte jetzt gar nicht so viel Hunger.
Ich dachte mir so, ein bisschen was essen, aber wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Das Gute war, Buffet war vom Catering. Und was macht das Catering?
Das Catering stellt eine Speisekarte auf.
Habe ich also einfach die Speisekarte fotografiert, in Chatschipiti hochgeladen
und gesagt, was kann ich davon essen?
Du bist ja ein klemmeres Kerlchen.
Und das hat hervorragend funktioniert. Also habe ich auch später noch mal im
Restaurant gemacht, auch wenn er irgendwie nicht davon zu überzeugen war,
dass Baby Spargel Baby Spargel ist und nicht Baby Paprika.
Aber trotzdem, dann kam halt eine ausführliche Analyse, ja, das enthält das
und das kannst du machen und das ist geeignet und das nimm mal lieber nicht
und nimm mal den Fisch, aber nimm nicht das und hier ist, ach,
das ist bestimmt zu scharf und das hat zu viel Zucker und ja,
das kannst du nehmen, aber lass die Soße weg.
Also wirklich irre und auch sehr spaßig, da so diesen Dialog zu pflegen und
an der Stelle muss ich sagen, gerade was so Rezepte auch betrifft,
dann so, ja, was soll ich denn jetzt überhaupt essen?
Ja, dann kannst du ja das, das, das, das machen. so, ah, okay,
also Kürbis und irgendwie Kartoffeln und irgendwie die Nacken habe ich dann
rausbekommen, alles okay, so, dann ja, machen wir mal ein Rezept davon.
Na, dann sagt er mir gleich wieder, wie ich da die Suppe machen soll,
Suppe gemacht, alles super.
Also, gerade so Rezepte ist so eine LLM einfach der Brüller,
weil da wiederum ist gar nicht so viel Scam.
Bei Rezepten nehmen es alle sehr genau, ne, und dann kriegst du halt auch ordentliche.
Kompositionen. Wenn du so diese typische Nerd-Problematik, Kühlschrank enthält
Dinge, irgendwas musst du jetzt essen, du willst oder kannst nichts einkaufen.
Kannst du einfach sagen, das und das ist in meinem Kühlschrank.
Was kann ich daraus machen?
Das Problem ist ja, dass es eben nicht nur der Kühlschrank ist,
sondern auch noch der Vorratsschrank und die Schublade mit den Dosen drin und so.
Ja, wenn man das auch hat.
Ist halt gut. Das muss man halt auch alles irgendwie mitteilen.
Also mir wurde, ich glaube, gestern oder so ein Rezept für Knollenblätterpilzsuppe
in die Timeline gespielt, als jemand mit der KI rumgespielt hat. Also ich weiß nicht.
Ja gut, den hast du ja normalerweise nicht im Kühlschrank.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber also Bilder in ChatGPT reinwerfen ist schon auch echt, zumindest von mir
noch, unterschätztes Killerfeature.
Ich hatte jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen den Fall, da musste ich wieder an
Roddy denken, der hätte mir das alles gut erklären können, hier so ein 200 Watt
USB-C Netzteil Dingsie.
Wegen seines akademischen Hintergrunds.
Wo kommen die 95 Prozent her oder Punkte?
Wo dann aber bei jedem der insgesamt irgendwie sechs Anschlüsse halt eine unterschiedliche
Spannung, Stromstärke, whatever irgendwie anlag.
Und ich dann also auch dachte so, entweder ich schicke das jetzt Roddy und er
erklärt es mir oder ich schmeiße es einfach mal in ShitGBT rein.
Und die Frage war halt einfach, an welchen dieser Anschlüsse kann ich mein iPhone
dran packen, sodass der Schnelllademodus anspringt.
So, das war einfach meine ganz alltägliche Fragestellung, die ich da hatte.
Und das wurde, würde ich sagen, dann famos in der Antwort gelöst. Und so sah das aus.
Was ich da hingeschickt habe, geht es gerade mal hin und das zahlt einfach die
ganzen Anstütze durch und es steht halt jeweils mit wie viel Ampere und wie
viel Volt die ausgestattet sind und dann gab es eine klare Antwort.
An die ersten beiden kannst du es dran packen.
Also Bilder machen und einfach mal reinwerfen. Gute Idee.
Okay.
Was stutzt du jetzt?
Einfach darüber, wie viel Information das jetzt hier ist. Aber ich würde einfach
mal sagen, kauf dir mal ein anderes Netzteil.
Warum?
Das ist frisch gekauft.
Was ist daran falsch?
Ich finde ein Netzteil sollte einfach an jedem Port das Maximum dessen was geht
Anliegen haben und nicht vier verschiedene Ports mit vier verschiedenen Dingern dran Was mich.
In deinem Netzteil stört ist dass es kein 15 Volt macht.
Es macht 12 Volt und 20.
Volt 15 gehört eigentlich auch noch mit zu Speck, sonst gibt es so Devices die
brauchen das Naja, okay.
Also auf jeden Fall war das ganz erfrischend. Ich kann jetzt noch nicht sagen,
dass ich jetzt in irgendeinem mentalen High gewesen wäre zwischendurch.
Aber man verliert ja enorm Gewicht. Also ich habe ja bis zu einem Kilo pro Tag abgenommen.
Ich habe dann allerdings jetzt auch schon wieder ein, zwei Kilo natürlich zurückerobert.
Es geht dann auch relativ schnell, wenn du was isst.
Ich bin dann leider in so eine Restaurantfalle gefallen und habe vielleicht
jetzt ein bisschen mehr gegessen, als nötig gewesen wäre, weil es schmeckt ja auch so gut.
Aber ja, ich würde es wieder machen und finde das an sich eine ganz gelungene
Sache und hoffe jetzt, dass es so ein bisschen dazu, also es macht einen automatisch
ein bisschen bewusster fürs Essen.
Also es ist, glaube ich.
Es soll so ein bisschen dazu führen, von allem weniger. Ich habe jetzt auch
erstmal so mit Kaffee trinken und so weiter ein paar Sachen.
Ich mache einfach erstmal bestimmte Sachen erstmal gar nicht und fange eigentlich
wieder an, mir rauszusortieren, was ich eigentlich wirklich haben will.
Ja, also ich bin da gerade auf dem exakt entgegengesetzten Ende der Skala.
Also ich mache im Moment so quasi Frust, Stress, Essen.
Und das ist natürlich das Schlimmste, was du überhaupt irgendwie machen kannst.
So das fängt an mit irgendwie Reste von Kindertellern das ist das Vater,
Problem schlechthin ich bin halt abends für die Küche zuständig und dann
hast du da halt einfach mal noch leckere Sachen liegen wo du denkst ah das kann
man und dann halt irgendwie dann hast du die den ganzen Tag hinter dich gebracht
und hast es endlich aufs Sofa geschafft und dann muss irgendwas muss doch da
noch sein und so und total ungesund da würde ich auch gerne wieder von runter
das wirkt sich auch nicht gut aus hier Ja.
Ich meine so ein bisschen Fitness und Spannkraft und so, das hilft einem ja
dann auch gerade, wenn man so im Job und sonst im Leben unter Strom ist,
da ist es ja kein Fehler auch fit zu sein, sonst versandelt man dann irgendwann total.
Und wenn man zu schwer ist, dann geht es dann halt auch in den Rücken und das
wird alles ganz schlimm. Naja, so viel von meinen Erfahrungen der letzten Woche in der Hinsicht.
So, wer mag reingrätschen?
Also ich habe ja noch so ein paar, ein größeres Thema und ein paar kleinere Themen.
Kann ich natürlich auch erstmal abpflücken.
Ja, mach doch.
Ich habe ein Gerät gefunden, das musste ich sofort kaufen. Ich habe es gekauft
und ich habe es vorhin bekommen und ich habe es innerhalb kürzester Zeit in
Betrieb genommen und ich bin einfach begeistert.
Ich habe genau das gefunden, was ich gebraucht habe.
Ich habe ja hier, wie ich schon berichtete, mit der Ebene berichtete,
eine HDMI-Matrix mir zugelegt.
Und ich hatte ein 4x4-Gerät gefunden, was ganz billig war und bin so ein bisschen
auf den Geschmack gekommen.
Und benutze das ja hier im Studio, wie ihr hier ja gerade seht und wie ich auch
schon mal beschrieben habe, einfach um flexibel zwischen verschiedenen Input-
und Output-Quellen kreuzzuschalten.
Das ist ja der Sinn eines Matrix-Switches und habe halt hier mittlerweile doch
diverse Einspieler. Also ich habe zwei Macs, die in der Lage sind,
so ein HDMI-Signal zu erzeugen.
Ich habe ein Apple TV, ich habe ein Raspberry Pi.
Damit habe ich also schon mal so vier Quellen, aber ich wollte eigentlich auch
noch mehr Quellen haben. Ich wollte auch nochmal ein HDMI-Kabel so auf dem Tisch
haben, wenn der mal da ist, dass man das einfach mal reinstecken kann,
ohne mal irgendwie mit Apple TV ins Sharing und es ist immer alles ein bisschen schwierig.
Hatte ich aber so nicht frei, so hätte ich dann immer umstecken müssen und wenn
du damit erstmal anfängst, kommst du in Teufels Küche und weitere Geräte sind
auf dem Horizont, die auch noch ein HDMI-Signal machen will und vielleicht will
man ja auch nochmal einen zweiten,
weiteren Dongle nochmal irgendwo ranballern aus irgendeinem.
Irgendwelchen Gründen, weil man nochmal ein Display braucht, keine Ahnung.
Und mein Einer-Monitor hatte auch noch einen HDMI-Eingang, den ich jetzt so
nicht habe nutzen können, weil ich eben mit den Devices, die ich hier habe,
einschließlich des Beamers, schon alle Ports hatte.
Mit anderen Worten, ich sehnte mich nach 8x8 und nicht nach 4x4 und hab dann
jetzt monatelang den Markt abgegrast und es war alles ein bisschen furchtbar.
Entweder hast du halt so sackteure Geräte, die irgendwie mit,
was weiß ich, 2000 Euro daherkommen, aber auch alle so ganz dünnlippige Manuals
haben und diese ganzen Webseiten haben mich alle schon überhaupt nicht überzeugt.
Dann hatte ich mir irgendwie so einen Teil von T-Smart gekauft,
einen Höllensound gemacht hat und mir auch wie am Ende nicht so richtig gefallen
hat, weil ich habe vor allem eins gesucht, was nicht nur in der Lage ist,
achtmal HDMI reinzuholen und achtmal HDMI.
Rauszuschieben, sondern es sollte sich auch noch ordentlich bedienen lassen
und es sollte vor allem für jeden möglichst jeden dieser HDMI-Ports auch das
Audiosignal nochmal analog oder auch digital raussplitten.
Und das macht fast keiner. Du hast entweder gar kein Audio oder du hast vielleicht einen,
der dann nur für Port 1 oder nur für Port 8 ist oder irgendwie so ein komischer
Kompromiss, wo man sich fragt, so was wie, warum und irgendwie war nichts für
mich dabei und das Allerschlimmste war,
all diese Buden sind immer irgendwelche China-Hersteller und wenn du dich da
mal so durchklickst und versuchst dann irgendwie Webinterface oder.
Dokumentation von den Protokollen oder also nur irgendeine Information zu bekommen,
dann war immer ganz schnell Ende und would you win, flower power Enterprises
und du wusstest irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr, wo oben und unten ist und ich
war unzufrieden mit der Gesamtsituation und mochte das nicht.
Aber hab mich trotzdem immer mal wieder alle paar Wochen aufgemacht,
weil mir dachte, verdammte Axt, das kann doch nicht sein,
dass da nichts zu finden ist und hab also so lange irgendwie den Google gewirkt,
bis er dann irgendwann mal eine
Webseite ausgespuckt hat, die erstmal ganz erfrischend aussah und das war.
4K Solutions, Erstens vor F-O-U-R-K-A-Y und die verkaufen tatsächlich ganz viel
HDMI-Kram, unter anderem auch ein 8x8 HDMI-Matrix-Switch,
der erstens ein ordentliches Interface hatte, das haben auch so manche.
Also mit anderen Worten ein Display und ein Display,
wo irgendwie du acht Tasten für den Input und acht Tasten für den Output hast
und du drückst auf den Output und auf den Input und dann hast du sozusagen eine Zuordnung gemacht,
dazu noch so ein bisschen Extratasten für so Menükram und ein kleines Display
und hinten achtmal HDMI rein, achtmal HDMI raus,
achtmal Analog Audio raus und achtmal Digital Audio raus, als Quarks in dem Fall.
Also so Cinch-Stecker, SPDV.
Und mein Interesse war geweckt. Und ich habe dann halt erstmal die erste Mail
da hingeschrieben, Support in der Laden ist in England.
Und meinte so, ja, ich habe mir nicht viel Hoffnung gemacht,
aber ich habe ja trotzdem mal hingeschrieben, wie sieht es aus bei euch mit Lüfter? Habt ihr einen?
Wie laut ist der? Das ist sozusagen mein Hauptthema.
Eine Stunde später hatte ich eine Antwort. Ja, Lüfter haben wir,
aber kannst du abstecken, Garantie erlischt dadurch auch nicht und so weiter.
Wenn der nicht zu heiß steht, passt schon.
Ein Mensch.
Menschen. Menschen, wie wir.
Menschen, die meine Frage verstehen und die auch sofort den Kontext verstehen
und nicht irgendwelche Sales-Droids.
Dann habe ich irgendwie so gleich nachgefragt, so, ah ja, okay,
könnt ihr mir das und das und das noch erklären?
Und dann so, ja, lalala, dies und das. Und dann ging also innerhalb kürzester
Zeit da so ein Thread hin,
wo es um tausend Features ging, ich irgendwie erklärt habe, was ich so,
was mein Einsatz ist, was ich so generell für Sachen noch gerne hätte und nachgefragt
habe, die es natürlich nicht drin hatten.
Also zum Beispiel, was ich ganz gerne hätte, ist, dass man für so ein Input-Port,
also ich habe ja so eine Taste für den Input-Port, wenn ich jetzt quasi den
Mac da angeschlossen habe und der Switch ist an, dann ist für diesen Mac der
Bildschirm immer da, selbst wenn er nirgendwo hingeroutet ist.
Und ich hätte halt gerne ein Feature, dass wenn der quasi nirgendwo hingeroutet
ist, wo auch ein Gerät an ist,
also wenn der Beamer aus ist und der ist auf dem Beamer geroutet,
dann soll quasi auch der Port zum Rechner hin aus sein, damit der Mac merkt, da ist nix.
Also sonst kannst du ja nicht ausschalten. Ich hatte ja schon von diesem Tool
Beta Display und davor auch diesem anderen Tool Luna berichtet,
was ich ja nur installiert habe, um genau das machen zu können,
um zu sagen, ich weiß, dass du einen Monitor siehst, aber ich möchte nicht, dass du ihn benutzt.
Und genau das Feature habe ich ja da drin.
Und wäre ja schön, wenn es die Hardware könnte. Ja, und dann war er ganz, ja, nee.
Und dann, ich frage auch nochmal bei den Technikern. Und ich glaube,
das geht nicht. Aber mal gucken und vielleicht kriegen wir da noch irgendwas hin.
Und ich war schon so entzückt allein von diesem Thread, dass ich zu dem Zeitpunkt
schon den Switch bestellt hatte.
Ich dachte mir so, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren. Und der ist irgendwie heute angekommen.
Ich habe ihn innerhalb kürzester Zeit in Betrieb genommen. Und das Ding funktioniert.
Es war jetzt ein bisschen teurer als der 4x4-Switch. Aber ich habe halt auch
gemerkt, wie wichtig mir das ist. Also dieses flexible Bildschirme hin- und
herschalten in so einer Studiosituation ist einfach mal ganz grandios.
Welche ist das jetzt?
Das ist der 8x, der günstige 8x8er, der heißt… With Atmos Downscaling and Smartphone Control.
Genau, das hat er alles irgendwie da drin. Also sie sind auch relativ gut.
Downscaling heißt, du kannst also für jeden Output-Port auch sagen, was der kann.
Also was weiß ich, hier der Beamer
zum Beispiel, da sage ich halt feste Einstellung, der kann halt nur 1080.
Wenn ich jetzt mit einer 4K-Quelle komme, dann macht er automatisch ein Downscaling.
Sodass quasi für die Geräte immer irgendwie alles 4K ist, aber wenn du es nicht
4K anzeigen kannst, dann ist es halt nicht 4K.
Aber auf dem Monitor, wo es 4K ist, ist es dann eben auch 4K.
Wow, du kannst sogar nochmal, achso eine IR-Ext, okay.
Genau, die ist dabei, das ist so Standard eigentlich bei diesen Geräten,
die eine Fernbedienung, eine Infrarot haben, dass du nochmal so einen kleinen Minijack hast,
das verlängert einfach nur das Signal, damit du das Teil unten irgendwo hinbauen
kannst, weil ich hab den jetzt hier so mit User Interface, mit dem User Interface
brauche ich überhaupt gar keine Fernbedienung mehr, das ist für mich viel besser,
aber wenn man das machen will, geht's.
Und es gibt dann auch noch die Möglichkeit, über RS-232-Schnitte da direkt in
so ein Command-Line-Interface einzutauchen und es gibt auch noch ein Telnet-Pod,
das wollte ich noch ausprobieren, ob ich darüber das machen kann,
weil mein Plan ist natürlich,
das alles auch fernzusteuern zu können und per Software da meine Quellen in
bestimmte Setups zu bringen, dass ich da nicht immer rumtippen muss,
sondern ich sage halt einfach Studio-Modus oder keine Ahnung. Umwand.
So. Das ist der Plan.
Ja. Also, erster Eindruck gut und mal gucken, wie es mir da nächstes Jahr mit
so geht. Aber jetzt bin ich erstmal galückelig.
Ja, 630 Pfund ist jetzt natürlich irgendwie nicht geschenkt.
Nee, der kostet halt ein Tausi, aber es ist halt ordentlich.
So, ist ein ordentliches Gerät. Es gibt den auch nochmal doppelt so teuer,
dann ist er auch seamless. Das heißt, dann hast du nicht dieses,
immer beim Umschalten, sondern der macht das quasi so mit digital Mixing und
du hast so instantanes Umschalten.
Für so Video-Vols ist das dann natürlich ganz wichtig, aber das war jetzt für
mich natürlich nicht ganz so relevant, weil ich will halt umstellen und dann
bleibt das auch erstmal eine Weile so.
Ich muss ja jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit hin und her schalten.
Von daher war ich jetzt mit diesem Gerät ganz gut bedient.
Aber ihr könnt einfach mal gucken, wenn ihr einen ordentlich gebauten,
HDMI, also sie haben nicht nur Matrix, sie haben auch so Cat5 Umsetzer und Controller
und Pipapo, ich habe mir die ganze Produktpalette noch gar nicht komplett gegeben,
aber die haben auf jeden Fall Support und das ist schon mal was wert.
Und sie haben so Video-Wall-Dinger, wo du dann, sehe ich das richtig,
dass man da irgendwie einen Eingang rein und dann verteilt er das auf mehrere Monitore.
Oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht angeschaut.
Ja, mal gucken. Also wie sie versprechen, HDMI 2.0 B.
Was auch immer das ist.
Das heißt auch nicht, wie bei HDMI ist eh alles optional. Das bringt irgendwie gar nichts.
Aber HDR haben sie irgendwie mit drin und Dolby-Kram auch in Audio und so.
Also das ist schon ganz ordentlich und wie gesagt, man kann die Lüfter abziehen.
Das ist für mich das wichtigste.
Es gibt sogar eine Smartphone-App. Ja, toll, oder?
Naja, mit der Smartphone-App, das muss nichts heißen. Zumindest nicht notwendigerweise was Gutes.
Ja, das ist einfach nur so eine einfache App, die nichts anderes macht,
als die Fernbedienung zu emulieren.
Also da hast du quasi dasselbe Interface wie auf der Hardware-Fernbedienung,
die ich aber jetzt eh erstmal nicht benutze.
Ich will mir das hier auf meinen Stream Deck XL packen, mittelfristig,
weil ich habe ja noch so ein XL rumliegen, was ich eigentlich mal gekauft hatte
in Erwartung einer größeren Nutzung, die dann nie eintraf. Hier habe ich so eine 4x8 Matrix drauf.
Das heißt, ich könnte mir da im Prinzip eine richtige Matrix auf die Matrix packen.
Die Matrix in der Matrix.
Yo, dog, I heard you like the Matrix.
Ja, also das wäre doch mal eine Anwendung, oder? Weil dann hätte ich so das
ideale User-Interface.
Einfach, tak, ich möchte jetzt gerne die Kombination, die Kombination.
Ja, also sowas sind ordentliches, schon was Feines. Also ich hatte mir für ein
Sendezentrum vor vielen Jahren mal so ein 4x2 Matrix-Switch geholt,
HDMI. Also vier Eingänge und zwei Ausgänge.
Da hatte man schon ja zwei Ausgänge reichen wahrscheinlich, weil wir jetzt vor allem Eingänge haben.
Und das war genau dieses Phänomen, was du eben beschrieben hast mit diesen Hiccups
zwischendurch. Und dann kommt der Handshake doch nicht so richtig zusammen.
Und dann musst du nochmal hin und nochmal wieder her.
Und gut, das hat halt auch nur 199 gekostet. Das ist dann nochmal irgendwie
ein anderer Preispunkt.
Aber am Ende ärgerst du dich dann halt dann doch auch recht viel.
Also HDMI ist schon irgendwie immer noch schwierig, finde ich.
Also ich habe da jetzt einfach investiert, weil ich weiß, das ist einfach ein
Gerät, was ich den ganzen Tag benutze, was für mich total wichtig ist.
Hier voll die Produktivität hochbläst und von daher passt das schon.
Muss man wieder ins Studio investieren.
Muss ja mal alles toller werden hier.
Jo, soviel dazu.
Rodi, magst du jetzt mal?
Ja, ich hatte eigentlich nur, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Kleinigkeit ist.
Dass das, ob das, und zwar habe ich da ein Video entdeckt, wo jemand mal auseinandergenommen hat,
wie das mit der neuen Richtlinie ist.
Die ist irgendwie vom März EU-Richtlinie über die Haftung, Produkthaftung für Software.
Und das ist sehr interessant.
Und zwar steht da im Wesentlichen drin, dass wenn man eine Software als Produkt
vertreibt, dann hat man dafür auch eine Produkthaftung. Ja.
Und zwar fast unabhängig davon, wie teuer die Software ist.
Also auch wenn man die verschenkt, muss man da eine Produkthaftung für übernehmen.
Interessanterweise gilt Source-Code aber nicht als Produkt.
Das heißt für Open-Source-Projekte, die ihren Source irgendwo hinlegen,
gilt diese Produkthaftung nicht.
Aber für jemand, der jetzt ankommt und aus der Open-Source-Software irgendwas
zusammenbaut und das dann veröffentlicht als Produkt, gilt die Haftung wieder.
Das Ganze ist, wie gesagt, jetzt gerade erst als EU-Richtlinie verabschiedet
und die Mitgliedstaaten haben, glaube ich, noch bis Ende 26 Zeit,
das in nationales Recht umzusetzen.
Denn solange das nicht passiert ist und dann die ersten Fälle auftreten,
ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht klar, was das für Konsequenzen hat.
Insofern ist es jetzt eigentlich auch ungelegte Eier. Also ihr könnt euch das Video mal angucken.
Ich finde es sehr interessant, auch wenn der Mensch, der das da besprochen hat,
das vielleicht ein bisschen sehr negativ sieht,
aber dass Leute, die irgendwas veröffentlichen, also bisher scheint es ja sowas
wie eine Produkthaftung für Software nicht so richtig gegeben zu haben.
Auch für Services nicht so richtig und damit wird es halt eingeführt und ich
persönlich halte das eigentlich eher für eine gute Sache, aber da muss man dann, glaube ich,
wirklich dann abwarten, wie es erstens in nationales Recht umgesetzt wird und
wie dann dieses Recht auch gelebt wird, bevor man da mehr zu sagen kann.
Aber ich denke, es ist auf jeden Fall was, was man mal im Hinterkopf halten
kann und wo man dann mal die Augen aufhalten kann, was das bedeutet.
Genau, da schreibt einer im Chat, neben Herstellern können auch Importeure und
Händler haftbar gemacht werden.
Sprich, wenn ich mir eine App aus dem App Store runterlade, dann ist erst mal Apple haftbar.
Wenn sie die Haftung nicht an denjenigen weitergeben können,
von dem sie die App haben.
Was sie bestimmt in ihren AGBs schon längst getan haben.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, bis jetzt noch nicht. Aber wie gesagt,
das ist ja auch erstmal nur eine EU-Richtlinie und noch nicht umgesetzt in nationales Recht.
Apple hat vor wenigen Tagen mal wieder ein Update gemacht.
Wie heißt nochmal diese Richtlinie?
Das kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen, wie die heißt.
Wie gesagt, also es ist ein bisschen früh noch, es ist ein bisschen noch ungelegte Eier.
Interessant ist, dass halt Softwarefehler auch, genau, Softwarefehler, die zu Schäden führen.
Es sind auch irgendwie Produkte dabei, die irgendwie in digitaler Form abgegeben werden.
Also in dem Video gibt er das Beispiel eine 3D-Druckdatei.
Wenn ich eine 3D-Druckdatei veröffentliche, die dazu führt, dass mein 3D-Drucker
kaputt geht aus irgendeinem Grund, weil die einen Fehler enthält oder so,
dann kann ich denjenigen, der die 3D-Druckdatei veröffentlicht hat, dafür haftbar machen.
Was?
Nach dieser Richtlinie.
Das ist aber problematisch.
Ja, da sind so ein paar Sachen drin, die im Zweifelsfall problematisch sind.
Wie gesagt, man wird abwarten müssen, zu was für Edge-Cases das führt.
Also da sind, wenn man so als Programmierer denkt man ja vor allen Dingen in
Edge-Cases. Eine Happy Path kann jeder.
Da sind so ein paar Sachen drin, wo offensichtlich Edge Cases sind,
die man nicht selber ausprobieren will.
Ja, für Fosszeug braucht es immer kommerzielles Bestreben.
Ja, kommerzielles Bestreben ist aber auch eine sehr schwierige Definition.
Also es ist halt, also wenn ich eine App auf dem App Store vertreibe und die
ist nur für umsonst, dann ist die Frage, ist das jetzt kommerziell oder nicht,
echt schwierig zu beantworten.
Also ich denke, wie gesagt, ich denke, das muss man im Auge behalten.
Es wird da sicherlich auch im Chaos-Umfeld noch heftig diskutiert werden und
wir werden sicherlich noch bei irgendwelchen Jahresrückschauen dann lachen.
General Product Safety Regulation, okay.
Aber momentan hat es noch keine Auswirkungen, weil das alles noch nicht richtig
gültig ist. Nur so als...
Beobachtet das mal, das wird noch spannend.
Ja, da ist ja dann auch die Update-Pflicht, glaube ich, auch mit dabei.
Ja, so Firmware ist zum Beispiel interessant. Also auf die Nutzungsdauer einer
Hardware kannst du plötzlich als Vertreiber des Gerätes für die Firmware haftbar gemacht werden.
Und zwar halt nicht nur, die Firma hat Fehler, die zu dem Schaden in dem Gerät
oder an anderen Geräten führt, sondern auch enthält Sicherheitslücken,
die ausgenutzt werden können und dafür wirst du dann haftbar gemacht und so.
Das wird alles sehr spannend.
Das wird auf jeden Fall ganz sportlich werden, genau. Genau. Und ja.
Wie gesagt, prinzipiell sehe ich das aber positiv, dass da mal jemand hingeht
und mal einfach den Finger in die Wunde legt und sagt,
Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht länger alle rausreden und fire and forget machen,
sondern wenn ihr ein Gerät auf den Markt bringt,
das potenziell in einem Bereich agiert, der zu Schäden führen kann,
dann müsst ihr irgendwie auch dafür haften.
Und dann wird es halt teurer, aber dann, weißt du, so, ich meine,
so einfach hier.
Das muss ich erst mal bewähren, das muss erst mal auch so in die Rechtsprechung
kommen und dann werden wir sehen, was es macht, das wird wahrscheinlich eine Weile dauern.
Ja, nur es ist halt so, es gab ja mal eine Zeit, ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht gibt es sie immer noch, wo Android-Telefone verkauft wurden,
auf denen Android-Versionen drauf waren, für die es ganz offiziell keine Updates mehr gab.
Und die dann entsprechend quasi mit Sicherheitslücke verkauft werden und du
kannst sie auch nicht mehr updaten und die Sicherheitslücke geht nicht mehr
weg. Und sowas geht halt überhaupt gar nicht.
Also zumindest für eine gewisse übliche Nutzungszeit muss der Hersteller dann
schon garantieren können, dass da kein Scheiß mit dem Gerät passiert.
Genau, müssen Updates bereitgestellt werden auf jeden Fall.
Und das finde ich gut, dass es dafür jetzt dann eine Richtlinie gibt,
die wird trennen, mit Sicherheit zu trennen führen bei manchen Leuten,
aber ich glaube am Ende des Tages werden die Dinge dann besser,
dadurch, dass sich die Firmen halt zusammenreißen.
Kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, was dabei rauskommt und vor allem wie lange das braucht,
bis das so richtig Traktion bekommt, weil das wird sicherlich nicht vom Start
weg irgendwie, da muss ja erstmal jemand verklagt werden und so und dann geht
das vorbei mal ganz schnell.
Ja, naja, aber ich meine, mal ganz ehrlich, sobald das Ding in Kraft tritt,
kannst du bei der nächsten großen Sache davon ausgehen, dass irgendwer eine Sammelklage lostritt.
Genau.
Die Dystopie ist halt, dass du dann quasi wieder… Ich hieß doch.
Diese Software, die die Flughafen lahmgelegt hat, vor ein paar Monaten.
Ach, das war die Firma, die ihre Software-Updates verteilt hat.
Ja, genau. Sowas in der Art, das ist dann interessant. Da stehst du als Sonderfirma
natürlich direkt vorm Abgrund.
Der dystopische Entwurf ist halt, dass du dann vergleichbar zu diesen ganzen
Abmahntrollfirmen halt dann wieder irgendwelche Geschäftsmodelle darauf aufbaust.
Ich wurde geschädigt durch Firmware XY.
Naja gut, du musst es natürlich am Ende des Tages beweisen können.
Naja, Fehler wirst du schon genug finden.
Aber er macht in dem Video ein schönes Rechenexempel auf.
Es gibt auch keine Schadensuntergrenze mehr.
Wenn du eine Million User hast und jedem User entsteht ein Schaden von 5 Euro,
dann bist du auch mit 5 Millen in der Kreide.
Das ist halt Crowdstrike, genau so hießen die.
Wenn diese Richtlinie schon in Kraft wäre und die Flughafen fangen plötzlich
an, Crowdstrike für ihre Ausfälle verantwortlich zu machen mit Produkthaftung
oder so, die wären jetzt pleite.
Ja, ich meine, wie gut es denen geht, weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Die werden ja auch direkte Verträge mit ihren Kunden haben.
Die haben trotzdem auch ein Problem schon, klar. Also bei uns in der Firma benutzen
wir es trotzdem immer noch. Also die Firma scheint es noch zu geben.
Aber ja...
Alright, gut. Dann kann ich mal von weiteren Dingen berichten,
die ich gemacht habe, außer Fasten.
Ich hatte ja in der letzten Sendung schon ganz kurz eingeworfen Cursor als neue
Entdeckung, die ich zu dem Zeitpunkt ein bisschen angeknabbert hatte und einen
ersten Eindruck bekommen habe.
Und dann bin ich so richtig ins Kanickeloch reingerannt und hab mal geguckt,
wie tief das eigentlich so ist und bin in einem totalen Programming Craze,
geendet.
Also ehrlich, ich habe in den letzten zwei Wochen mehr Software zusammenprogrammiert
als in den drei Jahren davor.
Wir können darüber diskutieren, was Programmieren jetzt in diesem Zusammenhang
überhaupt noch bedeutet, aber ich erinnere mich ja,
an deine ersten Experimente hier mit deiner Mastowall und so weiter,
JavaScript und die ersten dicken LLMs, das war dann glaube ich ChatGPT 4, oder?
Genau, die 4er Version war das vor anderthalb Jahren ungefähr.
Nun ist ja JavaScript wie Java und C und so, da ist ja nun das Internet auch
wirklich garstig voll mit,
Beispielen, sodass eben schon das Vierermodell da genug zu knabbern hatte,
um so seine Schlüsse rauszuziehen.
Mittlerweile sind die Modelle ja noch größer geworden und haben nochmal so diversen
Feinschliff bekommen und überhaupt glaube ich, beginnt die Welt auch erst langsam zu verstehen,
wie das alles nun eigentlich funktioniert und wofür man das benutzen kann und
wie man das am besten integriert und wie man das spezialisiert und die Fortschritte
sind in dem Bereich ja nach wie vor groß.
Zur Erinnerung, Cursor ist ein Editor, der von Visual Code geklont ist.
Also wenn man den startet, dann sieht ganz Optik ein bisschen anders,
ein paar Elemente mal horizontal, wo sie woanders vertikal sind,
aber im Kern nichts anders.
Man kann seine kompletten Settings importieren.
Und dann hast du den ganzen Kram. Also man ist sowieso schwupps mit einmal Return
drücken, ist man genau da, wo man mit Visual Code auch war und die Änderungen
im User Interface sind halt im Wesentlichen so gemacht,
damit man eben eine gute Integration für diesen ganzen KI-Assistenten-Kram hat
und dann kann man eben auswählen, was man so haben will und dann bin ich halt
losgezogen und hab gesagt, okay, jetzt gucken wir nochmal,
ob das jetzt auch mit Elixir richtig funktioniert, weil Elixir als etwas weniger
populäre Programmiersprache dementsprechend natürlich, Und weil sie auch noch
recht jung ist, also gibt es ja nun auch erst seit zehn Jahren, so richtig.
Also du hast halt einfach nicht ein komplettes GitHub voll mit Java,
sondern du hast halt ein bisschen Elixier im Vergleich.
Also keine Ahnung, ich kann das nicht quantifizieren, aber ich würde mal sagen,
im Vergleich zu populären Sprachen dürfte sozusagen die Menge an Diskussionen
und die Menge an Wissen und an Code, der da ist,
wenn er bei einem Prozent liegt, glaube ich, ist es schon sehr hoch. Das ist eher minuskul.
Ja und dann habe ich einfach mal angefangen ein paar Sachen zu analysieren,
habe also Code geladen und habe gesagt, hier liest ihr das mal durch,
erzähl mir mal was das macht.
Habe also Code von mir hochgeladen, also aus dem GitHub quasi das ganze Git-Repo
geklont und mal vorgeschmissen. Habe einfach gesagt, erklär mir einfach mal was das macht.
Genau und der entscheidende Punkt dabei ist über die komplette Codebase.
Genau, über die komplette Codebase. Man kann da halt einfach eine Frage eintippen
und dann drückt man nicht Return, sondern Command-Return und dann nimmt er sozusagen
die komplette Codebase und schaut sich das mal an.
Das heißt, im Idealfall weiß das Ding eben auch, wie die Dateien so zusammenhängen,
dass die zusammenhängen und grübelt dann ein wenig und lange dauert es halt
auch nicht und dann so, ja,
das macht das und dann macht es das und das und das und der Zweck ist wahrscheinlich das und das.
Und es stimmte einfach zu 100%. Also es war einfach exakt genau das,
was die Aufgabe dieses Programmes war, wofür es geschrieben wurde und hat auch
akkurat beschrieben, was es tut.
Da dachte ich mir erstmal so, okay, we are onto something here.
Und dann ging sie los, die wilde Fahrt.
Und meine erste Anwendung war tatsächlich erstmal was ganz anderes,
weil ich feiere leider immer noch WordPress.
Die dicke Tränen kullern.
Also ich meine, WordPress, ich hasse PHP.
Ich finde, PHP ist wirklich eine Beleidigung des Begriffs Programmiersprache.
Ich weiß, über die Jahre haben sie halt dann, wie alle Programmiersprachen,
die nichts können, angefangen, den ganzen Kram, den andere Programmiersprachen
gut machen, da reinzubauen.
Das ist so das Zeichen einer schlechten Programmiersprache, dass sie kurz nach
ihrem Start nur noch damit beschäftigt sind, das einzubauen,
was die anderen Programmiersprachen schon immer hatten.
Also am Ende wollen sie alle irgendwie, ich warte immer nur da drauf,
bis sie dann ankommen, so ja, jetzt haben wir auch Closures.
Da weiß ich immer so, okay, jetzt seid ihr also 1950 angekommen bei Lisp,
Hurra, gratuliere, dafür habt ihr jetzt nur 20 Jahre gebraucht.
Weil das ist ja eigentlich und das ist nochmal ein interessanter Detail,
was wir vielleicht nochmal, ich weiß nicht ob wir das schon mal so erwähnt haben,
aber wir reden jetzt über KI die ganze Zeit.
Künstliche Intelligenz der Zustand, wo wir das Problem haben,
dass wir den Computer nicht mehr so richtig vom Menschen unterscheiden können
wo die Sprache, die uns entgegenkommt so menschlich wirkt,
dass es für uns auf den ersten Blick und auf den zweiten und für viele wahrscheinlich
auch auf im fünften Blick, wirklich
Nicht mehr möglich ist, da noch in irgendeiner Form einen Unterschied zu machen.
Das war immer der feuchte Traum der Linguisten.
Und in den 50er Jahren, und da kommt der Begriff künstliche Intelligenz überhaupt her,
war es die linguistische Forschung, die versucht hat, das Problem,
was ist Intelligenz, was macht quasi den Menschen intelligent,
was ist der Unterschied zwischen Menschen und nicht intelligenten Wesen,
das haben sie ja an der Sprache festgemacht.
Wenn ein Lebewesen in der Lage ist, Sprache zu formulieren und zu entwickeln,
dann ist das ein klares Zeichen für Intelligenz.
Und wenn wir in der Lage sind, mit einer Maschine diese Sprache zu sprechen
oder zu verstehen, dann haben wir eine künstliche Intelligenz geschaffen.
Und was haben sie sich dann unter anderem als erstes Tool zugelegt,
um irgendwie diese Forschung voranzubringen?
Sie haben Lisp erfunden.
Lisp ist die Sprache, die aus dem Bedürfnis entstand, künstliche Intelligenz zu erforschen.
Funktionale Programmierung stand am Anfang. Da gab es halt Lisp in den 50er
Jahren und dann gab es Fortran.
Das eine hat irgendwie mit abstrakten Listenobjekten und funktionalen Konzepten
und Metaprogrammierung und all diesem Kram gestartet,
wo die meisten Programmiersprachen, wie gesagt, 30 Jahre brauchen,
bis sie sich dahin entwickelt haben.
Und nebenbei gab es halt noch für die Formelfreaks, die einfach nur Mathe machen wollten,
weil sie irgendwie Raketen steuern wollen, gab es halt Fortran und der Rest
musste halt irgendwie Assembler programmieren und dann kam erstmal eine ganze
Weile lang nichts und dann kam irgendwann so Basic und ADA und all diese ganzen.
Einzelnen Entwicklungen und Algol und also diese ganze Kaskade ich meine,
es ist nicht möglich alle Programmiersprachen aufzuzeigen, aber so in den 60er,
70er Jahren kam halt dieser Train überhaupt langsam erst mal ins Rollen,
aber angefangen haben die Hochsprachen im Prinzip mit Lisbon mit vortragen.
Ja, jetzt Plan, Kalkül und sowas weglassen.
Das ist Plan, Kalkül, ja, ja. Nee, Fortran, das stimmt schon,
war schon eine, und dann Forth, glaube ich, gab es noch.
Genau, Forth als Stack-orientierte Sprache. Dann gab es Prolog als Aussage-orientierte.
Also es sind verschiedene Modelle ausprobiert worden.
Am Ende kann man sagen, haben halt die prozeduralen Programmiersprachen erstmal
den größten Erfolg gehabt.
Hatten dann mit Pascal und später natürlich dann vor allem mit C so ein bisschen
auch so ihren Durchbruch und das war dann eigentlich so die erste populäre wirkliche Plattform,
auf der so Hochsprachprogrammierung aktiv dann in den 80er Jahren vor allem betrieben wurde.
Wobei man jetzt natürlich zu Recht streiten kann, ob man C als Hochsprache bezeichnen möchte.
Kann man, kann man. Aber so wurde es ja früher genannt, weil alles hoch war,
was über dem Assembler schwebte.
Klar, C war nicht allzu weit darüber, aber ja.
Genau, es war unmittelbar darüber.
War Stärke und Schwäche dieser Sprache.
Genau, also wenn du das so als Fischtank vorstellst und oben auf der Wasseroberfläche
schwimmt Lisp, dann hast du sozusagen als Bodensass hast du halt C.
Und alles andere ist irgendwo da zwölf. Als Plankton. Ja, das Plankton sind
halt irgendwie Ruby und irgendwie alle anderen Sprachen.
Java Script und Java und der ganze Quatsch.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist sozusagen die Komplexität und mich ist auf Lisp
gekommen, Spul zurück, Spul zurück, Spul zurück.
Also ich habe halt erstmal festgestellt, dieses System ist in der Lage,
also Cursor und die LLM, die ich gewählt habe, ist dieses Cloud 3.5,
was wir schon erwähnt haben.
Beziehungsweise ich habe auch mit ChatGPT ausprobiert und später gemerkt, Cloud ist besser.
Welche Chat-GPT-Version? Du hast glaube ich nicht die O1-Mini?
Nee, nicht die O1 genommen.
Also die O1-Mini soll von den
Chat-GPT-Modellen angeblich die für Programmierung am besten getunte sein.
Das kann gut sein. Habe ich nicht ausprobiert, weil mir eben gesagt wurde von
Luca, dass eben Elixir und Claude 3.5 a good match sind und dann bin ich damit
erstmal losmarschiert.
Ah ja genau, jetzt weiß ich wieder, wie ich drauf gekommen bin.
Ich hatte ja meinen WordPress-Server und wenn ich bei meinem WordPress-Server
in das Error-Log von meinem Web-Server-Enginex reinschaue, dann ist da Alarm.
Also es macht so Prassel, Prassel, also so, wenn jede Fehlermeldung ein Regentropfen
ist, dann war das also sozusagen Orkan.
Gigabyteweise immer wieder dieselben Fehlermeldungen mit PHP-Deprecation und
so, weil ich halt uralt Plugins gehabt habe, die seit acht Jahren von niemandem
mehr angefasst wurden und das PHP hat sich halt weiterentwickelt und es war einfach...
Wie so ein Geigerzähler?
Ja, genau so.
Exactly. Und das Problem war, dass ich halt gar keine Möglichkeit mehr hatte,
aus diesem Error-Log herauszulesen, ob wirklich irgendein Problem besteht oder
ob das sozusagen alles jetzt nur diese Warnings sind.
Und dann dachte ich mir so, okay, vielleicht werde ich das Problem ja jetzt
los. Und dann bin ich irgendwie losmarschiert und hab mir irgendwie ein Plugin
nach dem anderen runtergeladen, schön ordentlich in Git eingecheckt und hab
dann irgendwie mit Cursor gesagt, kannst du mir das mal auf PHP 8 modernisieren, bitte?
Ja, kein Problem. Hier, da, da, da, da, da, da, zack, accept, accept.
Dreimal accept gedrückt, abgespeichert, hochgeladen, lief alles noch genauso
wie vorher, weniger Fehlermeldung.
Das hab ich dann mit einem Plugin nach dem anderen gemacht. bis Ruhe im Karton
war und aus meinem wurde dann irgendwann so ein.
Also sprich, die Plugins waren im Wesentlichen Bandomware, wo keiner mehr irgendwie
aktuell in der Codebase gearbeitet hat.
Und du hast natürlich auch brav dann wieder als Pull-Request hochgeladen,
damit andere auch was davon haben.
Nicht wahr, Tim? Das hast du getan.
Dazu habe ich jetzt diese Änderungen zu wenig reviewt, um da jetzt so den Schritt schon zu gehen.
Aber ich habe sowas ähnliches getan, UBC.
Und ich muss ja erstmal Ruhe schaffen.
Ich wollte erstmal was machen. Dann habe ich ja überhaupt mal so ein bisschen
den Status aller Plugins überprüfen können, habe festgestellt,
so, ah, mein QR-Code-Generator, der irgendwie den schönen Bezahlcode erzeugt
auf der Spinnenseite, der funktioniert ja gar nicht, da ist ja gar kein QR-Code
mehr, beziehungsweise ich wurde darauf hingewiesen.
Da so, ah ok, Plugin kaputt kurz mal in das Plugin reingeschaut und so,
ja benutzt irgendwas mit Google,
auch wieder seit Jahren nicht gepflegt und halt das übliche und dann kurz ins
Plugin verzeichnet, ist bei WordPress geguckt,
was gibt's denn da so und es ist einfach immer die gleiche Soße Plugin macht
irgendeine sinnvolle Sache und dann,
ja kauf hier das Abo Pro Version und dann kannst du noch diesen Scheiß machen
und diesen Scheiß machen,
der dich nicht interessiert und alles kompliziert und Settings und hast nicht
gesehen und Neckware und Banner und irgendwie Leute,
wirklich QR-Code, bitte geht mir aus der Sonne. Und da dachte ich mir so.
Cursor gestartet. Ich möchte ein WordPress-Plugin schreiben.
Es soll einen QR-Code erzeugen und hier ist der Short-Code, auf den er reagieren
soll, weil es ist der, den ich vorher verwendet habe. Zack, Return.
Ja, kein Problem, hier musst du die Datei anlegen und hier dann das,
PHP, zack, fertig. So, aha.
Hochgeladen, QR-Code. Also, ich habe ein eigenes WordPress-Plugin geschrieben,
aber ich habe noch nie ein WordPress-Plugin geschrieben, wo so ganz viel ekliger
Boilerplate-Kram ist, was man da irgendwie alles deklarieren muss und pipapo.
Mit PHP, ich habe in meinem Leben keine Zeile PHP geschrieben und das Ding läuft.
So, macht einfach irgendwie das Richtige.
Und jetzt wurde die Sache langsam für mich immer interessanter.
So, dann dachte ich mir, okay, dann schauen wir mal, wie tief man hier noch
reinkrabbeln kann. Dann hatte ich noch so ein Plugin, das hat mir der liebe
Erik irgendwann mal geschrieben.
Der hat mir nämlich diese Anbindung an den Bezahldienst Stripe gemacht,
mit dem man über die Webseiten Apple Pay machen kann.
Als das nämlich frisch rauskam, Apple Pay in the Web, dachte ich mir,
das wäre doch mal eine schöne Sache.
Und dazu muss man halt da mit der Stripe-API reden und ja, ich möchte hier gerne
Apple Pay machen und wie können wir denn das hier machen und da muss man irgendwie
mit der API reden und lalala.
Und das schlummerte jetzt auch schon seit ein paar Jahren ungepflegt da irgendwie vor sich hin.
Funktionierte zwar tadellos, das war jetzt nicht das Problem,
aber mittlerweile gibt es ja auch Google Pay.
Da hat man ja so ein Google Pay.
Okay, Plugin-Cursor reingeschmissen. Ja, das Ding macht Apple Pay.
Kann das auch Google Pay?
Ja, überhaupt gar kein Problem. Das kann Stripe auch irgendwie.
Soll ich dir die Änderungen machen. Ja, mach mal die Änderungen.
Zack, Accepts, speichern, hochgeladen, zack, Google Pay.
Läuft, weißt du?
It just works.
It just works. Jetzt wurde es schon so langsam unheimlich.
Und dann habe ich so richtig die Ärmel hochgekrempelt und dachte mir so,
okay, alles klar, jetzt löse ich alle meine anderen Probleme am besten auch gleich.
Und bin irgendwie losmarschiert und habe dann irgendwie so andere Wehwehchen,
die ich zuletzt hatte, auch noch gelöst.
Ich als Buchhaltungsnerd habe natürlich vor allem immer das Problem,
dass ja keine, also wenn irgendwo Daten woanders anfallen, dann muss ich die
ja in meine Buchhaltung reinkriegen.
Und jetzt habe ich gerade dieses Subscribe durchgeführt und dann hast du so.
Ticketverkäufe, Ticketstornierung, da geht also die ganze Zeit irgendwie Geld hin und her.
Das klippert dann auf deinem Konto rum und erzeugt da irgendwelche Buchungen. Aber das ist ja nur Geld.
Was du ja brauchst ist, du musst ja wissen, was ist denn das jetzt für ein Geld?
Das hat jetzt irgendwie Storno oder sind das Kontogebühren? Ist da Umsatzsteuer drauf?
Wenn ja, wie viel Umsatzsteuer ist denn da drauf?
Damit du das irgendwie korrekt verbuchen kannst, weil du musst ja auch irgendwie
melden und jetzt willst du echt nicht jedes Ticket einzeln eintippen und im
Prinzip habe ich ja die eine Seite der Gleichung schon gehabt und die andere
lauerte dann halt in Stripe.
So und ich habe auch so mit Rest-APIs und so irgendwie mit Elixir auch noch nicht so viel gemacht.
Ich dachte mir so, Okay, probiere ich das mal aus und habe dann irgendwie angefangen,
meinen kleinen Stripe Monkey zu bauen, der dann halt so, ja,
red mal hier mit Stripe und ich möchte mal gerne hier auf die ganzen Rechnungen
zugreifen und im Prinzip habe ich mir quasi alle Rechnungsposten,
alle ausgestellten Rechnungen runtergeladen.
Habe die nach ihrem Typ und nach ihren Steuern korrekt irgendwie separiert,
ordne das irgendwelchen Buchhaltungskonten zu und habe mir ein schönes CSV draus
gemacht, was ich irgendwie direkt in die Buchhaltung importieren kann.
Der Vorgang war halt, ich habe immer Schritt für Schritt mit Cursor geredet
und habe gesagt, okay, das ist jetzt der nächste Schritt, den ich gerne machen möchte.
So, da hol mal die Rechnung runter, hab mir das angeschaut, ja,
schreib doch erstmal dieses ganze JSON, was da kommt, schreib das mal in so
eine Datei, dass ich mir das mal angucken kann.
So, dann hat er das gemacht, dann habe ich mir das angeschaut,
dann habe ich so gecheckt, so ist die Struktur.
Viel wusste das System auch, aber es war immer so ein bisschen so pick und poke,
man musste erstmal gucken,
was ist da jetzt eigentlich, welche Daten will ich jetzt eigentlich miteinander
machen, wie muss jetzt diese Rest-AP-URL genau strukturiert sein,
damit man so bestimmte Werte expandiert, damit man quasi so Unterinformationen
auch gleich mit einem Zugriff bekommt, also willst du nicht nur die Rechnung,
sondern willst du auch die Rechnungsposten haben und so weiter.
Naja, da habe ich mich dann so durchgemuggelt und es war einfach die ganze Zeit
so mit Cursor, als ob irgend so ein Senior-Developer neben dir sitzt auf dem Stuhl,
gutmütig dir beim Programmieren zuschaut und immer wenn du eine Frage hast,
kannst du mal so links rüber gucken, so wie macht man das jetzt?
Ja, da muss ich hier irgendwie und guck mal da und da und dann so,
ich mach dir das mal schnell.
Und der verstörend gut versteht, was man eigentlich will.
Und das Schlimme war, da kam nicht nur Code raus, der funktioniert hat,
Der Code sah auch richtig geil aus.
Also es war wirklich sauberestes Elixier.
Die Namings der Funktionen, der Variablen. Everything made sense.
Wenn du sagst, ich hätte es gerne ein bisschen anders, dann hat er sie auch
alle wieder umbenannt, wenn irgendein Aspekt wegfiel und Dinge wieder weggenommen,
die nicht erforderlich sind oder zusammengefasst.
Und ja, und dann hatte ich halt sozusagen meinen Exporter, habe das in meine
Buchhaltung importiert, alles hat gepasst auf Anhieb. Es war einfach Magie.
Vorher war der Weg, irgendeinen dusseligen Excel-Export runterladen und weil
irgendwelche Metadaten fehlten, muss ich da nochmal von Hand beigehen und dann
das nach Kategorien zusammenfalten und zusammenfassen und daraus manuelle Buchungen machen.
Und jetzt habe ich sozusagen jeden einzelnen Vorgang als Buchung und am Ende
geht einfach alles auf den Null auf. Das ist einfach der totale Knaller.
Dann dachte ich mir so, okay, jetzt geht es richtig. Zu dem Zeitpunkt war ich
also wirklich so in a freeze, am häkeln.
Vor allem, das habe ich jetzt irgendwie in zwei Tagen irgendwie alles gemacht.
Also jedes einzelne Problem hätte mich sonst eine Woche Recherche wahrscheinlich und Lernen gekostet.
Und so war ich irgendwie in zwei Tagen mit all diesem Kram fertig und ich war
ja noch lange nicht am Ende.
Und, achso, ich habe mich übrigens gerade getäuscht, das war natürlich nicht
Stripe, sondern es war Pre-Tix in dem Moment, wo die Ticketsverkäufe gelaufen sind.
Also das war quasi das Tool damit.
Strype habe ich mir dann aber auch nochmal vorgenommen, weil ich noch was anderes
im Auge hatte weil, wir reden ja nachher über unsere Lieblingsprogramme,
aber was ich ja so richtig heiß finde, ist ja,
Money Money ist ja nach wie vor einfach die geilste Software unter der Sonne
also wer sein Banking ohne Money Money macht,
auf Mac, hat das Licht nicht gesehen und gehört in Behandlung zu gehen Das ist
einfach, wenn ihr ein Bankkonto habt, dann wollt ihr Money, Money haben.
Ja, ich habe allerdings, ich habe vor ein paar Tagen tatsächlich ein Edge Case gefunden.
Es gibt irgendwie so komische Bezahl-QR-Codes und das unterstützt das leider nicht.
Zumindest Giro-Codes.
Wie auch immer die heißen. Also wenn man ein Stück Papier hat,
das jemand einem zugeschickt hat und da ist dieser QR-Code drauf,
hast du keine Chance. das mit Money-Miner zu bezahlen.
Es gibt keinen Girocode-Scanner, das ist richtig.
Da war ich etwas genervt.
Was natürlich auch in diesem bekloppten
Girocode liegt, der halt auch überhaupt nichts sagt, was er ist.
Also du musst, wenn du den scannst, wissen, was es ist, um dann diese Metadaten
dort einzulesen. Weil es sind nur so mehrere Zeilen Text.
Ja, ich habe mir das dann angeguckt, was da drin stand und dachte mir so.
Wer macht denn in Jahre 20.
24, so einen Standard. Leute, habt ihr den Schuss nicht gehört?
Es ist eine totale Katastrophe. Überhaupt keinerlei Selbstbezeichnung.
Wahrscheinlich Fortranprogrammierer. Ja, ja, genau.
So, Stripe. Und das Ding ist, du kannst bei Money Money gibt es ja,
wenn ja quasi so, alle SEPA-Banken werden unterstützt.
Also das ist ja quasi, Michael sitzt ja da dran. Also alles,
was irgendwie normal SEPA macht. Das ist ein Wahnsinniger.
Der Typ.
Ja, das ist unglaublich. Und was für einen Aufwand fährt, unfassbar.
Auf jeden Fall kann er aber jetzt auch nicht wirklich jede Entität auf diesem
Planeten, die in irgendeiner Form countingfähiges Material liefert,
unterstützen und deswegen gibt es ja das Plugin-Interface.
Heißt, man kann mit Lua quasi so ein eigenes Web-Scraping oder eben auch Rest-APIs bedienen.
Und so gibt es von jemand geschrieben ein Stripe-Plugin, was ich schon länger
benutze, um sozusagen alle Transaktionen, die man auf Stripe dann angesammelt
hat, also wenn dann quasi zum Beispiel mit Apple Pay was bezahlt wird,
dann bekomme ich das quasi als wäre es ein Konto.
Weil genau genommen ist es ja auch ein Konto, aber ich möchte es halt auch gerne
in Money Money als Konto abgebildet sehen und so weiter. Da fehlt mir bloß schon
immer ein paar Features in diesem Tool.
Was in Lua geschrieben war. Nicht
so. Schnell mal in die Telefonzelle gesprungen und ab geht da der Peter.
Und dann habe ich halt irgendwie dieses Tool ausgebaut und habe endlich mal
die Features eingebaut,
die ich da schon immer haben wollte, weil er hat dann mal irgendwie den Kontostand
falsch angezeigt und nicht irgendwie zwischen gebuchten und nicht gebuchten
Sachen unterschieden und ich wollte dann noch ein paar mehr Metadaten,
die verfügbar waren, aber die dann halt nicht geholt wurden mit einbauen.
Das habe ich dann alles noch in dieses Lua-Skript auch noch mit Cursor eingebaut
und das funktioniert mittlerweile auch total zuverlässig.
Ja, und dann habe ich mir noch ein kleines Shownotes-Tool gebaut,
irgendwie, was ich bei Logbuch Netzpolitik mache und das war dann auch wieder so Magie.
Dann so, ja, hier ist so ein Blob auf Text, da sind irgendwie 30 URLs drin,
löst die mal auf, guck mal, was der Titel der Webseite ist, bau das mal alles
so zu ordentlichem HTML zusammen. So, okay, habe ich.
Funktioniert. Und dann so, hm, dauert ganz schön lange das Ding aufzulaufen,
so, weil Also eine URL nach dem anderen so und dann war er da irgendwie so 30
Sekunden zugange und dann so, ja kannst du das auch alles parallel machen?
Ja kein Problem, zack, fünf Zeilen geändert, weil mehr musste ein Elixier dann
auch nicht machen und dann dauert das alles nur noch irgendwie zweieinhalb Sekunden.
Das ist einfach der Knall, so ging es irgendwie die ganze Zeit weiter,
also ich war super produktiv besitze hier noch ein paar anderen Ideen.
Und dann habe ich noch so Scherze gemacht wie da bin ich richtig in Verzückung
geraten ich habe einfach so Code genommen, wo irgendwie gar nichts fehlte,
wo alles schön war. Ich habe gesagt, gibt es irgendwelche Stellen,
die man sozusagen noch etwas eleganter ausdrücken könnte, mehr im Sinne der Programmiersprache?
Okay.
Also ich wollte sozusagen einfach nur den Beauty-Contest gewinnen und sozusagen
jedes Sprachkonstrukt, was sich mir anbietet für einen bestimmten Fall,
auch so effizient nutzen, dass ich nicht irgendwas anderes nehme.
Und das war wirklich das Geilste, Weil dann einfach so, ja, guck mal hier,
da kannst du dir nicht nur eine Zeile sparen, du drückst auch mehr damit aus
mit dieser Struktur, wie du es eigentlich gemeint hast und so weiter.
Also super intelligente Iterationen, rekursive Funktionen und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Also es ist eine Freude, damit zu arbeiten. Also es macht so einen Spaß.
Man muss allerdings aufpassen. Also jetzt mal zu den Pitfalls und den Nachteilen,
weil das klingt jetzt alles so rosy.
Was habe ich gelernt? Also erstens, auch diese Code-LLMs haben dasselbe Problem
wie die anderen LLMs. Das sind so Kinder, die du dir sehr leicht einschüchtern kannst.
Und wenn du irgendwas von ihnen verlangst, was sie in dem Moment aber gar nicht
lösen können, kommen sie trotzdem mit irgendeiner Antwort, weil sie halt Angst
haben, nicht behilflich sein zu können.
Und ich habe dann den Fehler gemacht, ich habe einen Bug gehabt.
Ja, hier, ich kriege eine Fehlermeldung. Also, ja, dann probiere doch mal das. Zack.
Also, ja, nee, gar kein Problem. Hier ist die Änderung und so weiter,
der Bug ist gefixt. Ich ausprobiert, hat sich gar nichts geändert.
Und dann so, ja, hier geht immer noch nicht. Hm, oh, das ist aber komisch.
So, ja, dann probier doch mal das.
Und so ging das so drei, vier, fünf Mal. Und die Antworten wurden immer skurriler.
Und Debug-Statements. Und er
wollte, dass ich alles mögliche überprüfe und so. Und ich dachte mir so.
Weißt du, ist da die Strategie.
Weißt du, worauf ich so?
Irgendwann wird ja schon die Lust verlieren, Tim.
Und der Fehler, den ich gemacht habe, war, Ich habe zwar die ganze Zeit diese
Änderung angebracht, aber ich habe gar nicht das durchcompiled und wirklich
die Änderung getestet, sondern ich habe die ganze Zeit getestet.
So, so, und die NLM ist also schuld.
Nein, nein, aber das habe ich dann halt gemerkt.
Ja, ja, oh gut.
Und das war dann aber so ein Lernprozess, weil man merkt schon,
wenn die so ein bisschen anfängt zu schwitzen.
Also da muss man also ein Gefühl für bekommen, wenn so die Antworten so ein
bisschen ausweichend sind und so ein bisschen verzweifelt wirken auch schon,
dann könnte unter Umständen das Problem daran liegen, dass man gerade die Unwahrheit
gesagt hat und gar nicht die richtige Fehlermeldung bringt.
Das ist wie, es wird ja gerne gesagt, dass in manchen Ländern die Leute ungern
unhöflich sind und wenn man nach dem Weg fragt und die wissen,
den Weg nicht, dann schicken sie dich in irgendeine Richtung.
Hauptsache sie haben eine Antwort geliefert.
Genau.
Ja, das ist die japanische Verhaltensweise.
Ich wollte jetzt das niemandem unterstellen.
Das ist sozusagen genau in der Kultur halt auch so, du musst dann auch irgendwie
zu irgendwas gut sein in dem Moment und auch wenn du es nicht kannst.
Und hier unser Lieblingsfilm 2001, Hell 9000, gibt es ja auch die Theorie,
dass er nur deshalb ausgeflippt ist, weil er lügen musste.
Weil wir ihm als Menschen plötzlich ein Verhalten auferzwungen haben,
was gegen seine eigentliche, ich will doch immer nur hilfreich sein und das
richtige Tun Natur geschehen ist.
Ja, das, bist du durch oder kompetiere ich ein bisschen?
Und vielleicht noch eine zweite Anmerkung, man muss...
Ähm, vorsichtig sein mit dem Scope.
Also das Ding kann schon sehr umfangreiche Revrites machen, Vereinfachungen
machen, Refaktorierungen machen, das geht alles.
Aber man kann sich auch verrennen.
Und was ich in dem Zuge überhaupt jetzt das erste Mal für mich so richtig urheber
gemacht habe, ist so mit Git und mit Branches zu arbeiten.
Also da macht das auf einmal richtig Sinn.
Ich habe das ehrlich gesagt bisher etwas vernachlässigt und das hat mir jetzt
das doch gelehrt, dass man eben vorsichtig sein muss, dass man sagen muss,
okay, jetzt habe ich hier einen stabilen Ding, jetzt ist das mein Main,
jetzt probiere ich was Neues aus, dann mache ich erstmal einen Branches.
Dass man auf jeden Fall wieder zurückkommt, weil man verrennt sich sonst und
die AI verrennt sich mit einem mit und man darf und das ist noch die dritte Lehre.
Ich habe dann irgendwann, ich bin irgendwann in so einen Modus gekommen,
wo ich gedacht habe, das funktioniert hier immer, accept, accept,
accept, bis irgendwie alles nur noch Garbage war und ich vor allem überhaupt
nicht mehr verstanden habe, was der Code macht. Und das geht natürlich nicht.
Das heißt, ich habe letztlich nur Code geschrieben, wo ich auch das Gefühl habe,
der kommt von mir, den habe ich abgesenkt.
Ich habe mir jede Zeile angeschaut, ich habe mir das Ergebnis angeschaut.
Ist das so, wie ich es schreiben würde? Verstehe ich, was da geschrieben wurde?
Sodass ich schon auch sagen kann das ist schon meine Programmierung auch wenn
sie so vorschlagsbasiert ist aber ich habe sie in dem Moment auch verstanden
es entbindet mich nicht jetzt bei dem PHP Plug-in,
bei diesem super simplen schon, aber bei diesem.
Ernsthaften langfristigen Ziel, das ich da hatte mit Elixir,
da muss ich dann schon auch on track bleiben und muss da reingehen und ich habe
dann auch oft Vorschläge abgelehnt, hab gesagt so,
nee, das gefällt mir nicht, wie du es machst, mach doch mal die Methode und so.
Dann kommt er dann auch so, ja, stimmt, hast du eigentlich auch recht.
So, das ist ja viel eleganter und so, ja, weißt du, so Sachen wie,
ich hab gesagt, ja, lock mal irgendwie die Nachrichten.
Dann macht er eine Funktion Lock und schreibt irgendwie einfach mit Put S irgendwie nach draußen.
Und dann meinte ich irgendwann so, ja, wir benutzen nicht das Logger-Modul.
Ja, ist ja auch recht, irgendwie, ist ja viel elixiermäßiger und dann machen
wir das jetzt irgendwie so und so die Geschichten.
Und ich habe darüber auch viele neue Interfaces kennengelernt,
APIs besser kennengelernt,
Sprachkonstrukte besser gelernt und man traut sich auch,
schneller an Änderungen an, vor denen man so vorher so ein bisschen Angst hat.
Man kann erst mal so voranalyseieren. Was müsste ich denn eigentlich machen?
In welchen Schritten müsste ich jetzt rumgehen?
Was müsste ich für einen Aufwand machen, um das Ding hier von Python in Elixir zu übersetzen und so.
Mindestens so als Programmierplanung kann es schon helfen, weil man erst mal
analysieren kann, man kann sich erklären, was macht das Ding?
Vom Freund habe ich so ein Python-Skript bekommen, so 1300.
Zeilen, Python-Code, komplett undokumentiert, irgendwie liest sich wie Geigerzähler
und keine Ahnung, was es macht.
Ja, kurz mal gesagt, ja, kannst du mir mal analysieren, was es macht.
Super akkurate Beschreibung, Schritt für Schritt, was das Ding tut.
Das ist einfach der Knaller. Also dieses klassische Problem von du übernimmst
Code von anderen Leuten und keiner hat eine Ahnung, was dieser Code macht. Die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Du kannst jetzt das einfach in den Cursor reinladen und kannst erst mal erklären
lassen, was denn das eigentlich tut.
Und zwar nicht nur so, was macht der Code, sondern bis hin zu,
wofür das eigentlich gedacht ist. Total stunning.
Zumindest seine Interpretation des Ganzen.
Ja, ich wusste ja, was das Skript tut, aber ich hätte es dem Skript selbst so nie angesehen.
Zumindest nicht auf den ersten Blick und nicht bevor ich es eine Stunde lang studiert hätte.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja sag mir mal, was das macht und hat genau gesagt,
was das macht, ohne dass ich irgendeinen Tipp gegeben habe, was es machen könnte.
Und das ist schon wirklich erstaunlich und da ist es, also die 20 Dollar pro
Monat, das hat sich mal echt gelohnt.
Genau, das ist für die Clot-Lizenz.
Das ist für die Cursor-Lizenz, mit der du für alle Premium- Modelle,
das ist O1 4 bei ChatGPT und Cloud 3.5 500 Fast Requests pro Monat hast.
Du hast mir das ja gezeigt, hier bei unserer Q207-Besetzung,
habe ich da immer drauf geguckt und fand vor allen Dingen erstmal das UX-Konzept
auch cool, was sie umgesetzt haben da in Cursor. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob wir das in der letzten Sendung schon mal erzählt hatten.
Nein, das sollten wir auch nochmal tun.
Dann versuche ich das jetzt einfach mal, weil ihr habt also nach wie vor euer
großes Fenster, in dem halt euer Code steht und oben hast du in den Tabs halt
die einzelnen Dateien organisiert.
Und dann schaltest du dir links dazu dann halt ein Chatfenster,
wo du dann halt in klassischer Menier halt mit der LLM disputierst und sobald
sie aber halt irgendwelche Codevorschläge macht,
sind die so als Codeblock-Element halt erstmal in den Chat eingebunden und werden
jeweils gut interpretiert und erläutert.
So, hiermit versuche ich folgendes Problem zu lösen und am Ende nochmal eine Zusammenfassung.
Das sind jetzt nochmal hier so deine Management Summary und dann kannst du bei
jedem einzelnen Codeblock halt dann sagen,
ja will ich oder will ich nicht und hast dann in der Main Window dann auch wirklich
so ein Diff View, wo du siehst so ganz klassisch in Rot die Zahlen sind weg,
in Grün die Zahlen sind hinzu.
Hast an der Seite so eine Quick-Nuff-Leiste, wo du sehen kannst,
welche Bereiche in dieser langen Datei wurden hier verarbeitet.
Und das ist natürlich so viel komfortabler als das, was ich mir mit der Masterwall abgebrochen habe.
Also hört euch die Sendung an, vor anderthalb Jahren muss es gewesen sein.
Das war ja ein einziger, irrsinniger Copy-and-Paste-Zirkus, den ich da hatte.
Dass du das überhaupt zum Laufen gekriegt hast.
Wo dann also wirklich ständig halt irgendwie, oh, jetzt ist der Kontext ja zu
lang, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, okay, mach jetzt nur die Veränderungen und
schreibe aber dazu, an welcher Stelle.
Das war wirklich alles ein Schmerz. Und als ich dir da über die Schulter geguckt
habe, wie hier das UX jetzt aufgebaut ist, dachte ich so Aha,
okay, gut, das probieren wir jetzt dann doch nochmal aus.
Ich würde sagen, ich hätte die Masterwall sicherlich in ein Fünftel der Zeit,
hinbekommen, jetzt mit Cursor.
Das wäre noch sehr, und ich habe ja damals schon nur anderthalb Tage gebraucht.
Also es wäre irre schnell gewesen.
Und ich habe das jetzt mal ausprobiert, in den letzten Tagen, an zwei Beispielen.
Und zwar, wofür das, finde ich, echt cool geeignet ist, hattest du gerade eben
auch als Beispiel Abandonware.
Ja, du nutzt irgendwas auf GitHub, was Open Source ist, wo der,
die Entwicklerin sich einfach mal davon gemacht hat, weil Leben dazwischen kommt
und mein totales Verständnis und keinerlei Vorwurf, aber es gibt ja einfach
so etliche Tools, die ich total gerne nutze, wo ich denke,
ah, da fehlt nur dieses eine Feature.
So, das kann doch jetzt nicht so schwer sein, das dazu zu bringen.
Und dann schreibst du das erstmal als Feature-Request, als Issue auf GitHub
und es passiert halt jahrelang nichts.
Und eine der Software, wo mir das total auf den Keks geht, weil ich es immer
noch doch ab und zu oder sogar relativ regelmäßig nehme, ist Breadboard.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, auch schon mal vorgestellt in der Freakshow.
Das ist, ich werfe mal den GitHub-Link hier rein.
Das ist eine Software, mit der man KI-generierte Bilder vernünftig durchbrowsen und durchsuchen kann,
um also zu gucken, okay, welches Modell wurde da verarbeitet,
wie war denn der Prompt von den Bildern, um nämlich dann so Qualitätschecks
machen zu können, wenn ich am Prompt variiere, kriege ich dann irgendwie eine
bessere Qualität hin von irgendwie Landschaftsbildern, ist das Licht irgendwie
besser gesetzt, wie auch immer,
um also einfach etwas systematischer mit KI-Bildgenerierung umgehen zu können.
Und was mir immer total gefehlt hat dabei ist, das hat eine FAF-Funktion,
dass man so sagen kann, so das sind die Prompts, die sind besonders effektiv,
die kannst du gut recyceln und um das aber beurteilen zu können,
musst du halt von diesem Thumbnail-View, wo die ganzen Bilder erstmal auf seinem
Bilderteppich drin sind,
um das beurteilen zu können, musst du halt in so ein Preview-Fullscreen rein.
So und ich wollte aus diesem Fullscreen-View, wo du nämlich die Entscheidungs-
Kompetenz plötzlich dann hast, ist das jetzt ein FAF oder ist das kein FAF?
Da wollte ich einfach aus diesem Screen heraus mit einem F-Key das als Favorit
auch einfach deklarieren können.
Konnte die Software aber nicht, sondern du musstest den Preview wieder verlassen
und musstest das kleine Herzchen dann irgendwo in den Thumbnail-Teppich anbringen.
Also so eine klassische UX-Geschichte, wo du einfach viel zu viele Klicks hast,
weil irgendjemand den Workflow nicht so hat, wie du ihn hattest.
Gut, ich also jetzt das Repo halt gezogen und reingeworfen in Cursor und gesagt so,
als erstes erstmal hier Add Codebase und dann guckt ihr erstmal an,
wie ist das alles aufgebaut und macht ihr erstmal einen Überblick und was macht
denn das hier und exakt derselbe Effekt, den du gerade beschrieben hast,
es hat glasklar beschrieben, was da irgendwie Phase ist bei der Geschichte.
So, ich will nur ein einziges Feature hinzufügen, nämlich und dann relativ detailliert
halt beschrieben, was willst du detailliert beschreiben, ist ja klar, was du willst.
Einfach die bestehende Favoriten-Funktion über einen Short-Key aus der Preview-Ansicht steuern.
So, und dann kam so dieser klassische, ich finde, das hat immer so was von so
einem aufgeregten Hund.
Oh, ja, super Idee. Das bauen wir. Ich habe hier einen Ansatz.
Erstmal erweitern wir das Datenmodell. Da müssen wir mit Favoriten umgehen können.
Und hier baue ich dir mal einen Event-Händler, womit wir mit den Tastatureinrücken
rumgehen. und dann machen wir noch diese und dann rödelt er irgendwie in sechs
Dateien rum ich gucke mir das so an,
Ah, Moment mal, also das ist doch aber doch eigentlich alles schon da.
Also du hast schon deinen Händler für Tastatureingaben in dem Programm drin
und es gibt diese FAF-Funktion schon und du musst das Datenmodell überhaupt
nicht erweitern und ich will einfach nur einen ollen Shortcut haben in einem
View, wo er derzeit nicht drin ist.
Oh, ja, jetzt, wo du es sagst.
Also diese Übereifrigkeit, erstmal so ein Standard-Template irgendwo rauszuwerfen.
Ich laufe schon mal los.
Das war schon so ein Downer. Also ich habe dann nach ein bisschen rumgeprokelt.
Es hat dann auch nicht auf dem ersten Anhieb perfekt funktioniert,
aber es lief dann noch ein bisschen Debugging und diese Iterationsprozesse hast
du alle schon beschrieben, muss
ich nicht wiederholen, wie man sich da so Debugging-mäßig dran arbeitet.
Aber irgendwie so nach 15 Minuten hatte ich mein Feature, immerhin.
Und dann dachte ich so, ach, was soll der Geiz? Ich schreibe die App jetzt einfach selber ab.
Mir fehlen auch noch andere Sachen. Ich hätte nämlich gerne so eine kleine Statistik-Funktion
gehabt, dass du nämlich dann nochmal ausgelesen bekommst über dein ganzes Bilder-Repository,
welche Texte hast du überhaupt verwendet und wie viele wie oft und dass du die
kombinieren kannst und dann live gefiltert wird und so.
Das hatte ich mir alles schon mal so zusammengebaut, das hätte ich gerne.
Ich habe das schon mal in Zwift probiert mit meiner alten Copy and Paste Taktik
und ChatGPT 4 war das damals.
Und das ist krachend gescheitert. Also das in Zwift zu machen,
das hat überhaupt keinen Spaß gemacht.
Was vielleicht auch ein bisschen an der Sprache liegt und ich kann nur auch
wirklich ganz, ganz wenig Zwift, wenn überhaupt.
Und das habe ich dann irgendwie nach ein paar Stunden bleiben lassen,
weil da habe ich also echt überhaupt keinen Land gesehen.
Und von daher habe ich wieder das gemacht, was hier mit Masterwall ja auch gut
funktioniert hat. ja, middle of the road, baust einfach so in JavaScript.
Und dann fing er auch an, ich setze erstmal einen Node-Server aus.
Nein, du setzt jetzt keinen Node-Server auf. Das brauchen wir hier nicht.
Es läuft alles schön clean, einfach nur hier in meiner Browser-Session.
Alles andere ist überkomplex.
Na gut, okay, dann würde ich mal Folgendes vorschlagen. Und dann kam aber,
würde ich sagen, so die geilste Entwicklerstunde meines bisherigen Software-Lebens.
Das war dann genau dieser Flow, den du eben beschrieben hast.
Also so from scratch ging da einfach, jeder einzelne Schritt wurde richtig gut
und effizient sofort verstanden, sofort umgesetzt.
Also du darfst halt nicht hingehen und irgendwie deine Wishlist runter tippen,
sondern du musst halt Schritt für Schritt ein Verständnis dafür haben,
was ist ein logischer Ablauf, in dem du sowas halt irgendwie sinnvoll aufbaust.
Und dann lief das aber eine Stunde lang wirklich perfekt. Und ich dachte,
wow, das ist sehr viel besser als das, was ich vor anderthalb Jahren hatte.
Also weil da die Qualität der Modelle echt nochmal nach oben gegangen ist.
Der Unterschied zu dem, was du gerade mit Alexi erzählt hast,
ich kann nach wie vor kein JavaScript, ich will es auch gar nicht können.
Das heißt, nach fünf Minuten habe ich komplett aufgegeben, überhaupt noch in den Code zu gucken.
Und habe einfach nur noch Accept All und wenn irgendwas nicht lief und die erste
Stunde lief, kam aber auch gar keine Fehler. Ich dachte auch wirklich, okay, was ist hier los?
Das ist jetzt wirklich die nächste Generation hier.
Es lohnt überhaupt nicht mehr, auf den Quellcode überhaupt drauf zu gucken und
es macht trotzdem exakt, was du willst.
Und das war wirklich Christmas Tree Approach, so Feature an Feature an Feature
dran gehängt. Und er hat das alles locker hinbekommen.
Nach einer Stunde kam ich irgendwo an der Punkt, wo die Komplexität dann zu hoch wurde.
Das waren so ab 700 Codezeilen ungefähr.
Das war auch so der Punkt bei der Masterwall, wo es anstrengend wird.
Also irgendwo ist dann das Element.
100?
Ja.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht so viel.
Das ist nicht so viel. Der hat dann, also ich habe auch immer wieder mal so
Refactoring-Sachen reingegeben. Achtung, guck mal, wo du optimieren kannst. Refactoring.
Schreib das nochmal um. Mach da Tadellos und schwupps, hast du wieder 100 Kurzzeilen weniger am Ende.
Das lief alles schon noch ganz gut. Und dann kommt aber halt dieser Moment,
wo die Sache dann ein bisschen schwammig wird.
Und genau wie du beschrieben hast, dafür muss man ein bisschen ein Gespür haben
und das hast du natürlich dann doch nur, wenn du irgendwie schon mal was programmiert hast,
so okay, jetzt wird es hier gerade so ein bisschen fuzzy und der erste Anlauf
klappt nicht und der zweite auch nicht und der dritte auch nicht und eigentlich
ist die Lösung aber relativ simpel und wie sage ich es ihm jetzt,
dass er es einfach mal simpel probieren soll und nicht mit Standard Framework XYZ.
Aber jetzt so nach den insgesamt drei, vier Stunden Beschäftigung,
ich finde die Tür hin zu Product Owner können plötzlich ihren eigenen Code schreiben
und ihre eigenen Apps entwickeln.
Mindestens mal als Prototyp ist jetzt mal sichtbar geworden mit dieser Cursor-App.
Weil das, was ich da mit Copy and Paste gemacht habe, da würde ich sagen, das war halt Nerdtum.
Und jetzt bist du halt auf einer Ebene, wo Leute wie wir mit wenig Zeit,
aber coolen Ideen plötzlich irgendwie produktive Sachen runter programmiert,
in Anführungszeichen, kriegen.
Und das hat mich schon beeindruckt. Also wir haben da, glaube ich,
jetzt sehr ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht.
Also, wo es auch hilft, ist, ähm,
so, was weiß ich, hier auch beim Podlove-Projekt, verfolge ja so verschiedene
Sachen und dann komme ich halt immer mit meinen Sonderwünschen.
Ja, können wir nicht nochmal das einbauen?
Können wir nicht nochmal das einbauen? Und was, wenn wir so Programmierer reagieren,
wenn so andere Leute kommen?
Da muss man doch nur und so. Mal eben.
Roddy schüttelt schon den Kopf, das kennst du. So, und jetzt bin ich irgendwie
in einen anderen Modus gegangen. Ist mir egal, PHP oder was auch immer.
Ich will jetzt hier dieses Feature bauen, dann hole ich mir den Code,
mach das und stelle einfach einen Pull-Request und schwupps,
nächsten Tag war das schon im Release und weißt du, das wird dann eh nochmal
reviewed und du hast aber quasi schon mal so die Vorlage,
gebeten oder du kannst auch nur so ein Proof of Concept machen,
es muss gar nicht darum gehen, dass du wirklich die finale.
Lösung lieferst, aber du kannst es mir schon mal zeigen, so hier guck mal,
grundsätzlich läuft das im Browser, es performt auch ein bisschen und so hätte
ich das gern oder du zeigst auch einfach nur so ein,
du machst auch quasi nur so einen Entwurf, was du dir so vorstellst für so einen
bestimmten Bereich im User-Interface oder welcher Funktionalität oder Dateiformat
oder was es auch immer ist.
Also all diese ganzen Sachen, die sonst immer noch relativ viel so Setup-Power
brauchen, Boilerplate-Production, wo du also irgendwie erstmal dieses ganze
Manifest runterbeten musst, bevor irgendwie diese Compiler überhaupt bereit
sind, mal mit dir zu reden.
Dann hast du also einfach, du kriegst quasi so die Eintrittskarte in alle Clubs.
Du hast also auf jeden Fall schon mal so eine City-Card zu allen Programmiersprachen der Welt.
Du darfst da überall schon mal Straßenbahn fahren und mal rausgucken und mal
gucken, wie es denn da so ist.
Ich habe auch sogar versucht, Swift zu erzeugen.
Ich wollte so ein Share-Sheet Plugin auf Mac machen, also quasi eine Mac-App,
die so ein Share-Sheet macht und dann die URL an so einen Bookmark-Service gibt.
Das hat er mir dann tatsächlich programmiert. Ich habe es jetzt leider noch
nicht bis zu Ende gebracht, weil ich es dann festgestellt habe,
dass dieses Raindrop, wo ich das reinwerfen wollte, weil es hat aus irgendwelchen
Gründen sowas nicht auf dem Mac.
War dann nicht in der Lage in seiner Konfiguration die richtigen Callbacks anzunehmen.
Das habe ich jetzt als Bug gemeldet und da geht es aber gerade nicht weiter.
Also das ging technisch sozusagen gar nicht.
Aber ich habe halt auch diesen ganzen Swift-Kram gemacht in Cursor,
obwohl ich das immer mit X-Code,
umsetzen musste. Und Xcode ist ja komisch, dass ich das erste Mal das Xcode
benutze habe. Also das ist ja merkwürdig.
Aber sie hat mir auch immer erklärt, was ich in Xcode machen muss und diese
Änderungen dann auch wirklich...
Ihr Opa, ich helfe dir mal über die Straße.
Ja, nee, da musst du noch Ad-Files machen und das hinzufügen und mit fünfmal
in welches Modul muss das jetzt wirklich rein, hin und her und irgendwann gab
es dann keine Fehlermeldung mehr, aber schön war das nicht.
Ja, Xcode hat viel Geschichte.
Das habe ich gemerkt.
Und wenn man in der Welt nicht drinsteckt, dann ist es wie VI.
Also VI ist auch so ein Editor. Leute, die den können, schwören drauf und alle anderen denken sich.
Was ist kaputt mit euch?
Genau, was ist kaputt mit euch? Oder Emacs ist genau das Gleiche.
Das ist auch so ein was ist kaputt mit euch Ding.
Und was ich an Xcode ganz gut finde, ist, dass er sich halt wie eine Standard-Mac-App
verhält und auch die meisten Shortcuts so benutzt.
Ansonsten ist, hat, also, ja, also ich glaube, ich wäre jetzt hier der Beste,
um sämtliche Probleme von Xcode einmal runter zu rattern, aber das erspare ich euch.
Da wollen wir jetzt nicht hingehen.
Schlimm ist halt nur, dass das, also es scheint bei Apple,
ganz viele Produktmanager von Xcode zu geben und die einen, Die bauen immer
fancy neue Features außen ran und die anderen versuchen es irgendwie lauffähig zu halten,
aber so viele Versionen von Xcode sind auch einfach technisch kaputt und funktionieren
immer nur so halb und du musst genau wissen, wie du das Ding irgendwie am Leben hältst,
wenn gewisse Dinge nicht mehr funktionieren.
Und Derived Data wegschmeißen ist immer so ein Ding, was man gerne mal machen
muss. Obwohl jetzt mit Xcode 16 ist es wieder besser geworden.
Aber dass ich sowas allein sage, ist einfach eine Zumutung.
Also Apple müsste da eigentlich nochmal komplett aufräumen und irgendwie dem
geneigten Programmierer mal was vorsetzen,
was nicht ganz so clicky-bunty ist und aber einfach technisch robuster. also das ist so.
Mir ging es ja jetzt auch gar nicht um X-Code sondern nur darum,
dass man auch das mit Cursor hinbekommt also ich habe es natürlich jetzt final nicht testen können,
aber vielleicht nehme ich mir nochmal die Zeit und schaue mal,
ob es prinzipiell hätte funktionieren können,
aber sogar so eine Sachen lassen sich damit tacklen mit anderen Worten,
für Leute also ich würde sagen, es gibt zwei,
zwei,
drei User-Gruppen, die da was von haben.
Für Profis ist das eine extreme Zeitersparnis. Was wir nicht erwähnt haben,
ist ja zum Beispiel diese Tab-Completion.
Also wenn man irgendwo so eine Änderung macht und du hast so was wie,
ich will jetzt aber, dass hier überall nochmal Unterstrich, Unterstrich vor
den Symbolen steht und dann hast du so zehn von denen da drunter.
Die alle irgendwie so mehr oder weniger in der gleichen Datenstruktur drin kleben.
Dann gehst du da einfach rein, machst schon mal deine ersten beiden Unterstriche,
dann kommst du sofort so überall so, ja, wenn du jetzt Tab drückst,
dann mach ich das da unten auch überall rein. Das ist wohl das, was du willst, oder?
Und es war bisher immer das, was ich wollte. Also völlig irre. Sprich,
Nur wenn du Code schreibst, ist das schon eine große Hilfe. Jetzt habe ich ja
nicht so viel geschrieben.
Ich habe eigentlich nur die ganze Zeit mit diesem Apply-Funktionen gearbeitet
und über diesen Chat gearbeitet, aber schon auch Boilerplate erzeugen,
überhaupt erstmal die Datenstrukturen, Funktionen fertig zu schreiben,
all diese ganze Schreibarbeit,
da ist es schon mal eine große Hilfe.
Also Profis haben auf jeden Fall was davon und du kannst eben auch so advanced
Sachen machen wie auf Security Probleme checken.
Refactoring machen, also dir automatisch Tests erzeugen für den ganzen Klimpim,
den du da gerade zusammen gemacht hast.
Also Sachen, die normalerweise auch viel Zeit kosten oder zumindest etwas Zeit
kosten von deinem Budget und dann bleibt dir einfach mehr Zeit darüber nachzudenken,
was du eigentlich jetzt wirklich tun willst.
Das würde ich sagen, ist so der erste Tier, also für die etablierten Programmierer,
die genau wissen, was sie tun, wo das Ding einfach wirklich mehr schon wie so ein Taschenmesser ist.
Dann so zweite Zielgruppe ist so Leute wie wir, die so schon Programmieren an
sich verinnerlicht haben, für die das jetzt nicht so total eine neue Welt ist.
Auch mal mit einer Programmiersprache, die man noch gar nicht kennt.
Und vor allem auch um Code, der schon existiert, zu modifizieren,
aber vielleicht auch kleinere Projekte from scratch überhaupt erstmal bis zu
einem bestimmten Punkt zu bringen, dass sie schon hilfreich sind. Dafür ist es wunderbar.
Und so dritte Zielgruppe, die ich sehe, ist Programmieranfänger,
die eine Programmiersprache oder Programmieren an sich lernen wollen.
Weil du kannst ja losgehen und sagen, ich möchte gerne die grundlegenden Dinge
dieser Programmiersprache verstehen und kannst allein im Chat dich schon mal
über die Programmiersprache unterhalten,
ohne dass irgendwie Code groß geschrieben wurde.
Und ich würde immer noch empfehlen, wenn man jetzt wirklich in eine Programmiersprache
eintauchen will, es gibt da immer ein gutes Buch, das man gelesen haben sollte.
Meistens auch genau eines.
Meistens genau eines. Und das sollte man auch nach wie vor tun.
Nur habe ich halt oft das Ding gehabt, ich dachte so, ja wieso,
ich habe doch genau das geschrieben, was das Buch mir jetzt gesagt hat.
Wieso habe ich da jetzt einen Syntagsfehler?
Man sieht einfach den Wald vor lauter Bäumen nicht.
Und dann machst du einfach zack, markieren, kannst mir mal sagen,
was da falsch ist, erklär mal. Und dann kriegst du es einfach erklärt.
Und dann ist so, aha, okay, gut, habe ich jetzt auch verstanden.
Also das ist definitiv auch etwas, was einem die Angst nimmt vor dem Programmieren,
weil man quasi, ja, Senior Developer sitzt direkt neben dir und ist immer bereit zu antworten.
Er hat unendlich Geduld, wird nichts peinlich finden, was du ihn fragst.
Ja.
Ja, also ich bin ja auch echt so Generation-Data-Bäcker-Buch.
Also ich brauche auch ein echtes physisches Seitenbuch. Das sind die einzigen
Bücher, die ich überhaupt noch lese, sind echt irgendwie zu Programmiersprachen.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das jetzt halt auch einfach oldschool ist
und dass die Jugend da entspannter mit umgeht. Also du kannst ja sogar sagen,
entwickle mir halt irgendwie ein Kursprogramm.
So zehn Stunden ist der Timeframe und baue mal Lektionen und dann stelle mir
die Aufgaben und kommentiere den Kram und sowas.
Also auch solche Ansätze werden funktionieren.
Also probiert das wirklich mal aus, so egal welcher dieser drei Zielgruppen,
die Tim glaube ich gerade ganz präzise definiert hat, die ihr euch zuordnen würdet.
Weil in Cursor ist ja erstmal so eine Probelizenz enthalten für, wie ist da das Limit?
Du hattest es irgendwie mal rübergeworfen. Also auf der bin ich immer noch unterwegs
und ich habe halt irgendwie da schon etliche Stunden jetzt drin versenkt.
Damit kommt man schon zum Ausprobieren echt weit.
Also man muss kein Geld ausgeben, um da schon mal viel Spaß mitzuhaben.
Genau, also wählt halt als Modell entweder O1 Mini oder Cloud 3.5 Sonnet.
Also ich habe jetzt auch mit dem Cloud 3.5 die ganze Zeit das gemacht.
Also free ist zwei Wochen freie Trial, 2000 Completions und 50 Slow Premium Requests.
Ja, okay. Und dann gibt es halt diesen Hobby Plus und den Pro und Pro und Business.
Also der freie heißt Hobby, der 20 Dollar heißt Pro,
damit hat man natürlich Unlimited Completions, also diese Tab-Completion im
Editor und dann 500 Fast Premium Requests per Monster, also das ist,
wenn man im Chat quasi mit der LLM redet und dann egal, was du,
nimmst und,
nochmal 10 O1 Mini-Users per Day.
U1 Mini besonders toll.
Das ist ja das schnellere, getuntere Modell von O1 Preview, was jetzt auch glaube
ich das Preview gestrichen hat.
Ja, die sind jetzt glaube ich released worden gerade.
Genau, ein paar Tage her. Das gilt als besser im Coding noch als das große O1
Modell. Von daher ist das also jetzt für den...
Okay, aber das ist wohl noch sehr aufwendig. 10 pro Tag ist halt...
Das ist nicht viel.
Das würde man sich dann sozusagen für die speziellen Probleme aufheben.
Oder man zahlt 40 Dollar und dann hast du auch noch so Privacy-Modus,
Teambilling. Okay, das ist für große Firmen.
Das fügt jetzt dem AI nichts mehr hinzu. Aber ich denke mal,
diese Grenzen werden relativ schnell nach oben gehen für das gleiche Geld.
Und ja, da muss man dann selber sehen, was man will.
Ich habe gesehen, man kann da auch dieses Framework hinterhängen,
was ich in der letzten, vorletzten Sendung mal mitgebracht hatte,
wo man quasi einmalig Geld drauf wirft und du dann irgendwie dort die ganzen
Modelle im Zugriff hast. Wie hieß denn das nochmal? Ich vergesse das leider immer.
Muss ich mal in den Shownotes gucken, werfe ich gleich nochmal rein.
Achso, Open Router meinst du?
Open Router, genau. Wo man genau gesehen hat, so jeder einzelne Query,
wie viel Cent hat die eigentlich gekostet oder 0,002 Cent oder was auch immer.
Genau, danke.
Das kann man auch in dem richtig Cursor hinterlegen.
Man kann aber kein lokales Modell da irgendwie einpflegen.
Wäre ich mir gar nicht so sicher, dass das nicht, also deren Settings-Seite
fand ich war recht umfänglich.
Doch, da habe ich gleich noch einen Tipp dazu, den kann ich ja jetzt gleich mal hinten anwerfen.
Hast du schon von LM Studio gehört?
Das ist die Macintosh-Anwendung, die du auf deinem Computer mal runterladen möchtest.
Das ist nämlich sozusagen ein Language Model Studio, also ein Macintosh-Programm,
wo du dir Models lokal auf deinem Rechner laden kannst und mit allen irgendwie rumspielen kannst.
Das heißt, du kannst ja quasi so alles, was so im Netz Open-Source-mäßig als Model da ist,
so Lama und den ganzen Kram, direkt in dein Studio runterladen und hast sozusagen
ein User-Interface für diese Dinger und kannst mit denen lokal rumchatten und
auch mit irgendwie anderen vergleichen.
Und ich meine, da war auch eine Funktion drin,
wo du dann sozusagen einen lokalen Webserver starten kannst,
wo du dann sozusagen in so einer Konfiguration von so einem Tool wie Cursor
eine URL angibst, wo er denn sozusagen seine Requests hinleiten soll.
Und das kannst du dann sozusagen lokal auf deinen Rechner umleiten und dann
kannst du also mit dem lokalen Lama arbeiten und da hast du dann überhaupt gar keine Beschränkung.
Was Lama jetzt, wie gut der Elixier kann oder Swift,
kann ich natürlich nicht beurteilen, aber auch das wird sich natürlich demnächst
dann ändern und dann geht es sozusagen nicht auf Geld, sondern nur auf deinen
Prozessor und dann musst du halt mal gucken, wie viel RAM du hast.
Ach ja, fein, okay. Also mit den Open-Source-Modellen habe ich schon auch immer
länger rumprobiert und die sind halt alle derzeit, Stand heute,
echt signifikant schlechter jetzt als die Profi-Modelle, muss man sagen.
Aber das wird sich ändern.
Also klar, das ist jetzt auch so ein Hase-Igel-Race. Natürlich werden die kommerziellen
wahrscheinlich immer besser sein, aber ich glaube so der Gap hin bis zu,
okay, es ist jetzt wirklich nützlich und Open Source,
der wird in spätestens zwei Jahren, würde ich mal jetzt so schätzen,
wird der geschlossen sein.
Und dann sind solche Dienste natürlich hochattraktiv.
Luca wirft ja auch gerade noch einen ähnlichen Tipp ein.
Es gibt ja wohl noch so einen Editor, der so AI-Integration heißt. Der heißt ZZED.
Next Generation Code Editor.
Design for High-Performance Collaboration with Humans and AI.
Auch Open Source und neu geschrieben in Rust.
Aha, also vielleicht nicht so lahmarschig wie Visual Code.
Keine Ahnung, was der kann, aber auch hier kann man alles integrieren und der
kann auch mit lokalen Models arbeiten.
Also geht es sozusagen in gewisser Hinsicht mit beiden. Also mit Z habe ich
jetzt noch überhaupt keine Begegnung gehabt und ja,
Luca meint schon, der sei schneller. Das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen,
weil wenn er in Rust geschrieben ist und nicht in ganz viel JavaScript, dann...
Es ist dann nicht schwierig, schneller zu sein als JavaScript.
Selbstet. Ja, naja, also ich glaube, damit ist jetzt auch das Thema Programmieren
mit AI erstmal ganz gut erläutert.
So mal so machen kann man sagen, das passt schon und probiert das mal aus.
Da tut sich auf jeden Fall mal was.
Probiert das aus, auch wenn ihr mal so, ich wollte mir Programmieren schon immer
mal anschauen oder ich habe mal angefangen und hab's wieder aufgehört und sein
lassen oder bin da nicht vorangekommen oder so.
Dafür ist es genau richtig und dann kostet es auch erstmal nix.
Gut, womit machen wir weiter?
Jetzt bin ich ja schon durch hier mit meinen ganzen Tipps.
Das war super.
Dann haben wir ja noch Fragen gehabt. Ach, das haben wir ja gar nicht angesagt.
Ich hab noch einen Weihnachtstipp.
Weihnachten? Ich hab gehört, das kommt.
Ist das bald?
Ich muss aber erstmal an meine Jacke ran.
Das kommt auch irgendwie, das geht auch nicht tot.
Jetzt kommt Tatwert zum Einsatz.
Das soll noch über ein Jahr hin.
Weihnachten hast du jetzt Geschenke, du hast ja schon Geschenke,
du hast schon Lebkuchen ausgeteilt, bist ja wieder Weihnachtsmann Ralf, der Weihnachts-Ralf.
Jetzt gräbt er hier gerade noch in seinen Täschchen und spannend,
was jetzt hier verwichtet wird.
Wieder ein Schlüsselbund. Brillenhalter, sonst was.
So, also wir haben uns vor, weiß ich nicht,
drei Vierteljahr oder sowas, habe ich mal über meine Bestrebungen berichtet,
meine Hosentaschen und Jackentaschen irgendwie abzuspecken und dort diesen kleinen
Mini-Schlüsselhalter mal vorgestellt,
wo du deinen riesigen Hausmeisterschlüsselbundern hingeliehen hast.
So und ich habe jetzt das Pendant dazu seit ein paar Monaten im Einsatz,
nämlich eine Mini-Brieftasche.
Das heißt also, wo ich Kreditkarten und etwas Geld mit mir rumschleppe und das
Ganze in einem Format, was genauso groß ist wie eine Kreditkarte und nicht größer.
Und das ist also alles, was ich jetzt also noch bei mir.
Also nicht nennenswert größer.
Es ist dicker natürlich, aber vom Format her ist das also ein paar Millimeter
größer als eine Kreditkarte und das hat also diesen Mechanismus,
dass die Kreditkarten alle zusammen in so einer Box einfach reingesteckt werden,
also nicht irgendwo reinsortiert in irgendwelche Felder, sondern die steckt
man einfach in ein einziges Fach rein und dann hat man so einen kleinen Sprungmechanismus.
Wo man dran drückt und dann werden die alle aufgefächert einem angeboten und
man sucht die kreditkarte seiner wahl oder was.
Auch immer für eine karte was passt.
Oder was passt.
Da rein so eine box.
Die gibt es in verschiedenen größen ich habe jetzt eine in die irgendwie sechs
oder sieben karten drin passen so und was du dann halt noch hast ist hier so
eine aufbewahrung für scheine.
Bei Münzen, das hast du ja nur fürs...
Wo du Scheine dann eben zusammenfaltest, irgendwie ein, zwei Mal und die dann dort gehalten werden.
Und du hast an der letzten Lasche, die man rausziehen kann, auch noch ein kleines Fach für Münzgeld.
Drei Münzen oder so.
Ungefähr so Zehn Münzen oder sowas. Das Modell, was ich jetzt hier habe,
das ist von Sacred, heißen die.
Ich werfe das mal in die Shownotes rein. Es gibt etliche Anbieter,
die jetzt auf diesem Formfaktor irgendwie unterwegs sind.
Und für mich war halt die Frage, funktioniert denn das?
Also es ist ein Leben sinnvoll, vorstellbar, indem man wirklich genau nur das
irgendwie mit sich durch die Gegend trägt.
Kommt man mit so wenig Münzen klar? Kommt man mit so wenig Karten klar?
Und was soll ich sagen, es funktioniert ganz wunderbar. Ich will nie wieder
irgendwas Größeres haben. Es ist alles drin.
Ich habe es jetzt seit drei oder vier Monaten im Einsatz. Nichts anderes.
Und es reicht. Und es ist so eine Ebene von Reduzierung, die einfach hilft.
Also es wäre, glaube ich, schwieriger, wenn man nicht jetzt hier in Berlin ist
und dann doch schon mittlerweile 80 Prozent der Sachen einfach mit Apple Pay
und Uhr und Handy bezahlen kann. Also Berlin ist jetzt doch bei aller Möckelei
schon relativ weit mit dem bargeldlosen Bezahlen.
Das heißt also so häufig braucht man dann die Münzen auch gar nicht.
Aber für das, wo man sie braucht, reicht das, was hier drin ist.
Also,
Das Problem, was ich mit diesen Karten habe, ist, dass ja wirklich auch diese
Kreditkarten eine unglaubliche Verschwendung sind, weil das Einzige,
was man davon wirklich braucht, ist der Chip.
Und diese ganze Plastikgedöns drumherum, das ist irgendwie nur Deko und eigentlich
vollkommen überflüssig und eigentlich brauchen wir auch den Chip nicht,
weil das kann man in Software theoretisch halt sowieso alles emulieren und mit
Kreditkarten funktioniert das ja.
Das heißt so Kreditkarten habe ich so normalerweise gar nicht an Bord weil Telefon,
also das ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr super selten, dass ich irgendwo mal wirklich
nochmal eine physische Karte reinstecken muss.
Für das Geld abheben halt, ne? Also wenn du dann mal physisches, geiles Geld brauchst.
Richtig, da brauch ich aber keine Kreditkarte für.
Sondern?
Neue Bankkarte.
Naja gut, okay, gut. Also ich mache das alles Visa über die Kreditkarte.
Ja, du hast ja noch eine Visa Okay, ja gut. Du kannst dich dann auch für dein
Konto mit deiner Visakarte autorisieren?
Genau.
Bei welcher Bank?
Ingen-Diber.
Ah, okay.
Das machen die aber seit Ewigkeiten.
Ja, okay. Ja, Sparkasse ist irgendwie anders. Auf jeden Fall.
Auch das finde ich, ehrlich gesagt, absurd. Also warum kann ich mich nicht an
meinem Geldautomaten auch, weißt du, mit Piep-Piep authentifizieren?
Wie überall anders auch.
Mit Apple Pay oder Ja.
Das ist ja die Karte hinterlegt.
Ja, eigentlich müsste das gehen.
Naja, das ist schon möglich mit NFC.
Ja, ja, schon. Ich meine, es gibt genug Automaten, wo du Apple Pay machen kannst.
Also selbst hier ist es fair in der Autobahn.
Also vielleicht geht es nicht, weil Apple sagt, da muss auch mal Geld fließen oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Also es gab schon immer mal wieder Probleme. Zum Beispiel hast du,
wenn du einen Mietwagen mietest, dann wollen sie oft die Karte haben,
um die du sozusagen vorab ja diese Kautionsbuchung festgehalten,
was ja nur eine Reservierung ist.
Das ist eine Zahlungsreservierung, die die dann auch wieder freigeben kann.
Aber warum sollte denn eine Zahlungsreservierung über Apple Pay nicht auch möglich sein?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Da verhält sich dann doch die Karte jetzt irgendwie mit NFC auch nicht anders.
Das sind alles noch ein paar Fragezeichen, die ich habe.
Ich habe so Reservierungen auch einfach nur mit Kreditkartennummer eingeben.
Ja, ich hatte,
neulich in Paris was gemietet. Die haben noch nicht mal meine Bunkkarte akzeptiert.
Sie meinten, sie brauchten die richtige Karte. Ja, ich so, hier ist eine Karte.
Nee, das ginge ja nicht, das wäre ja eine Online-Bank.
Kennen Sie eine Bank, die nicht online ist? Ja, nee, aber das wäre so eine New
Bank, die machen wir nicht.
Aha, New Bank, ab wann ist denn die Bank neu und wann ist sie denn alt?
Das können Sie sich mal erklären. Und dann hatten sie ja irgendwie tatsächlich
da irgendeinen Klausel in ihrem Vertragsgedöns drin,
von dem ich irgendwie sicher bin, dass sie völlig gegen alle EU-Vorschriften
verstößt ging, mit Gleichbehandlung und Hass nicht gesehen, aber konnte ich
in dem Moment natürlich auch nichts machen.
Ich hatte Glück, dass ich noch irgendwo tief versteckt in einem anderen Wallet
hatte ich tatsächlich noch eine andere Idee, also hätte ich diese Karre nicht bekommen.
Und das fand ich dann doch schon wirklich ein bisschen merkwürdig und ich frage
mich vor allem, was die da für Erfahrungen gemacht haben, was irgendwie ihr
Vermietgeschäft betrifft, weil ich meine reservierter Betrag ist reservierter Betrag.
Wenn er reserviert ist, dann kriegst du den auch. Also völlig unklar.
Ja, aber die Franzosen sind da sowieso komisch. Also meine Ex-Frau hatte schon
mal das Problem, dass sie irgendwie war ein halbes Jahr in Frankreich und hat
da halt auch gearbeitet und dann hatte sie da natürlich,
um Geld zu bekommen, auch ein Konto eröffnet und dann wollte sie das Konto schließen.
Und da war das dann so, dass du das Konto nur schließen konntest,
also du hast dann das restliche Geld,
wenn du das Konto geschlossen hast, haben sie dir weder bar ausgezahlt,
noch haben sie einen Banktransfer an irgendeine IBAN gemacht,
sondern du hast nur einen Verrechnungscheck bekommen, den du nur bei einer anderen
französischen Bank wieder einlösen kannst. wenn du dort ein Konto hast.
Sprich, du... Ist bestimmt auch alles nicht erlaubt. Mittlerweile.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Das ist jetzt sehr lange her, aber das war auch so ein Fall,
wo man so denkt, na gut, dann behalten sie halt die 20 Euro.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall müssen wir diese Karten loswerden,
damit wir nicht so große Portemonnaies mit uns rumschleppen müssen.
Das ist irgendwie alles Quatsch. Was für Karten hast du denn noch,
außer Kredit und Bankkarte.
Ja, lass mal gucken, was habe ich denn hier eigentlich drin?
Ich habe natürlich meine Bibliothekskarte, die Föp-Karte.
Ja, aber diese Bibliothekskarte, ist die überhaupt elektronisch?
Ja, natürlich. Ja, mit unseren Selbstverbuchern, NFC, klar.
Und die kannst du nicht in deinem Telefon einlesen und replayen? Das geht auch bestimmt.
Gut, das sollte ich jetzt wissen. Ein bisschen beides.
Das NFC ist, nein.
So, ich habe drin meinen Führerschein.
Ja, okay.
Das ist jetzt auch im Kartenformat.
Den hätten wir natürlich auch gerne mal im Telefon.
Meinen frischen, neuen Personalausweis.
Ich weiß, ich war gestern bei der passenden Veranstaltung dazu,
da habe ich auch heute schon in LNP drüber berichtet.
Und halt meine beiden Visa, das heißt also die von meinem Spaßkonto und die
von meinem Familienkonto.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen so das Minimum. Naja, hast ja recht.
Mehr Karten brauche ich eigentlich auch nicht.
Dann gibt es, also ich habe hier noch die Gesundheitskarte. Die Bankkarte, die Visa-Karte.
Die Bahncard. Gut, die habe ich eigentlich auch im Telefon noch.
Genau, die ist doch digital schon.
Den Organspendeausweis.
Ah, guter Punkt.
Und die AirTag-Karte.
Die Bahncard ist doch jetzt eh abgeschafft als physische Karte.
Sie ist ja eh nur noch digital.
Ja, siehste, hier.
Ja, siehste was?
Kann ich zu Hause einrahmen?
Ja.
Was ist das schwarze da, das letzte?
Das ist die AirTag-Karte.
Ah, genau. Ja, das wollte ich auch mal bei mir noch reinbauen.
Das müsste auch noch Platz für.
Die ist aber nicht so geil. Also echte AirTags sind besser. Um es mal ganz ehrlich
zu sagen. Vor allen Dingen, weil das Teil auch immer leer geht.
Ja, stimmt.
Der da reingebaute Akku, der ist nicht so geil.
Hält nicht.
Nee, nee, nee.
Die muss ich auch mal wieder aufladen.
Tja. Apple wusste es vorher. Gut. Portemonnaie kriegt man ja auch immer auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt.
Ja, also falls ihr noch Geschenke Last Minute braucht, für Leute,
die ihr Leben vereinfachen wollen, schaut da mal vorbei. Ich würde sagen, das funktioniert.
Wie groß ist dein Portemonnaie? Sag mal her. Moment, ich hab jetzt noch auf die Karten geschaut.
Ich hab gerade weggepackt, da ist jetzt ein bisschen viel Zeug drin, aber...
Schon so, dass vom Volumen her ist dreifacher von meinem.
Ja, zweieinhalb bis dreifach von der Grundfläche, so anderthalb ungefähr. Aber ja.
Also, naja. Klar, wenn man das Mikro haben will, ist super, aber die paar Zentimeter
mehr, stört mich jetzt nicht groß. So, jetzt haben wir noch zum Schluss haben wir noch Fragen.
Fragen über Fragen.
Der Chat hat uns Fragen gefragt und dann haben wir doch gesagt,
okay, wenn ihr uns eh schon Fragen fragt, fragt uns doch noch ein paar mehr Fragen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir die alle abarbeiten können, aber wir können ja mal gucken.
Also ich fand die erste doch direkt gut. Was war euer Programm App des Jahres?
Von Jahren. Soll ich mal anfangen?
Mach mal.
Also es ist die Frage, wie das jetzt definiert ist. Also ist es sozusagen,
Welche App habe ich dieses Jahr am meisten genossen, überhaupt für mich erst
wieder entdeckt oder welche wurde neu dazugeladen?
Ich interpretiere das jetzt einfach mal, was ist für mich die App des Jahres
und zwar fange ich mit etwas an und dann werden jetzt hier alle hinten überfallen,
etwas, was es nur auf Windows gibt.
Ach, das ist doch keine Apps.
Das ist doch ein Echse.
Fan Control.
Das hatten wir, glaube ich, mal.
Fan Control ist eine freie Software, die relativ schön Lüfter in einem PC steuert. Weil Windows bzw.
Diverse Firmwares von diversen Geräten das auch nur so halb hinkriegen,
Kann man damit also schön für jede Temperaturquelle eine Kurve angeben,
bei wie viel Temperatur soll, wie viel, keine Ahnung und so weiter.
Und man kann Temperaturquellen zusammenfassen, also weiß ich nicht,
die fünf Temperatursensoren auf der SSD, nimm den Maximumwert und so weiter.
Und dann kannst du mit Regeln und so weiter, kannst du dann diverse Fanheader
auf deinem Mainboard so steuern, dass der Rechner kalt bleibt, aber auch leise.
Also ich meine, gerade bei Gaming-PCs ist das, glaube ich, relativ wichtig,
weil die halt relativ viel Strom verbrauchen, wenn man da relativ absurde Sachen mitmacht.
Ich weiß, das passt hier eigentlich nicht hin, aber ich fand die gut,
sie kostet nichts und sie funktioniert erstaunlich gut.
Das nächste ist fusion 360 das
ist für mich dieses jahr so quasi wie soll ich sagen damit habe ich jetzt den
einen den einstieg in die 3d drucker welt ja ich habe jetzt keinen link habe
ich den einstieg in die 3d drucker welt geschafft.
Fusion 360 ist nicht super geil,
aber es ist meiner Meinung nach ein guter Trade-Off zwischen,
man muss jetzt nicht unbedingt gleich so viel bezahlen und es kann aber trotzdem was.
Es ist leider von der Benutzung sehr hakelig.
Man muss sich einfach nur daran gewöhnen, dass man erst sagen muss,
was man tun will und dann kann man die Objekte auswählen, auf dass das,
was man tun will, angewendet werden soll.
Wenn man das einmal verstanden hat, dann wird es einfacher.
Das ist ja arschteuer.
Das ist, wenn man das kauft, ist es arschteuer. Aber man kann bis zu zehn Projekte
mit der freien Version und unter ab.
Also einige Features gehen nicht. Also man kann da ganze Getriebe simulieren
und Dinge tun und so weiter.
Und es gibt sogar inzwischen auch Elektronikmodule, wo du also tatsächlich eine Platine routen kannst.
Und dann kannst du Bauteile drauf tun und kannst du das simulieren.
Und dann kannst du auch noch ein Gehäuse dafür bauen und, und,
und, und, und. Das ist alles jenseits dessen, was ich damit mache. Aber das ist, genau.
Und dann, letzte Sendung hatten wir das. Ich hatte ja ein Mac Mini mir geshoppt.
Und dann war die Frage, was habe ich da als erstes drauf gemacht?
Das müssen ja jetzt auch die Apps des Jahres sein.
Sind im Wesentlichen Bartender. Das ist das Tool, um die Menübar aufzuräumen,
wenn man da zu viele Icons hat.
Das zweite ist Alfred, das ist so ein Startteil...
Ein Launcher, genau. Da gibt es auch andere Launcher. Ich will die Diskussion,
welcher jetzt gut und welcher schlecht ist, gar nicht anfangen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nochmal ein Holy War für sich.
Genau, das ist ein Holy War für mich. Für mich funktioniert Alfred ganz gut und fertig.
IStart Menus, besonders weil es da jetzt wieder eine neue Version gibt,
das ist halt so ein Teil, was einem relativ viele Sachen über,
was tut das System gerade anzeigt. Ich mag das sehr gerne.
So, dann Homebrew, das ist ja dieses System, mit dem man allerlei Kommandozeilen-Tools,
Open-Source-Kommandozeilen-Tools installieren kann.
Package Manager für YouTube.
Package Manager, genau. Irgendwie haben sie den auf Linux auch portiert,
finde ich ja auch mal irgendwie cool.
Genau, und natürlich ZFS.
Das benutzt du auf deinem Laptop?
Ja, auf dem Laptop auch, aber auch auf dem Mac Mini, ja.
Das, ah, okay.
Naja, wenn man so ein Gehäuse hat, wo ganz viele Festplatten drin sind,
die man irgendwie mit USB da ranbamseln kann, dann kann man da halt einfach
sein ZFS Dateisystem aufmachen und fertig.
Das Thema hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr in der Freakshow.
Aber Da ist auch schon lange nicht mehr allzu viel passiert.
Das letzte was passiert ist, was ganz geil ist, ist dieses Expanden.
Du kannst also aus einem Vierer-Rate kannst du ein Fünfer-Rate machen,
indem du da noch eine Platte ranhängst und dann verteilt er alle neun Dateien
auf fünf Platten statt auf vier,
Aber gut, das nur so am Rande Ja,
und ja, das war es im Wesentlichen.
Ralf?
Gar nicht so viel Neues, Spannendes entdeckt dieses Jahr.
Ich würde sagen, was bei mir so den größten Wow-Effekt hatte,
ist das, was ich in der letzten Sendung reingeworfen hatte, dieses Spatial Media Toolkit.
Ich mag halt einfach 3D und die Möglichkeit, irgendwie uralte,
Familienfotos von meinem irgendwie eigenen sechsten Kindergeburtstag oder sowas
in 3D auf der Quest anzugucken, das finde ich einfach Hammer,
dass die Technologie mittlerweile so ist, dass es nicht mehr doof und peinlich
und kaputt und improvisiert aussieht, sondern dass man denkt so, oh, das ist schon
ganz schön dicht dran, da hat sich also echt was getan.
Also das finde ich super. Ähm,
Und ansonsten, weil ich es auch wirklich täglich nutze, ist halt wirklich Chat-GPT
in der O1 und O1-Mini-Version.
Also zunehmend jetzt auch die Cloud 3.5 Sonnet.
Aber alle, die jetzt irgendwie immer sagen, so Plateau-Phase von LLM-Modellen und da geht nichts mehr.
Ich finde, die haben jetzt die Tür nochmal so ein großes Stück weiter aufgeschoben.
Es ist so alltagsnützlich für mich in so vielen Zusammenhängen,
dass ich mir nur denke, ihr habt ganz schön wenig Fantasie, wenn euch da nichts
zu einfällt, was man damit machen kann.
Das stimmt. Das passt?
Ja, ich glaube.
Ja, ich habe auch festgestellt, dass ich gar nicht so viel Neues habe und ich
würde mal dieses Cursor definitiv aber auf die Liste setzen,
weil das war jetzt einfach mal wirklich ein Enabler vor dem Herrn.
Also das ist sozusagen, das hat jetzt meine persönliche Produktivität hier um
ein Vielfaches gesteigert und damit natürlich erheblich beeinflusst.
Also kann ich nur so die Sachen nennen, die mich jetzt schon länger begleiten.
Also ich hatte noch dieses Remote-Buddy, das habe ich ja Anfang des Jahres vorgestellt
hier, meine ganze Fernbedienungslösung mache, aber das ist vielleicht jetzt
nicht für jeden so interessant und kann immer wieder nur betonen,
wie geil Money Money ist.
Ich habe natürlich auch mit ChatGPT jetzt relativ viel gemacht.
Ich mag ein Chat-GPT tatsächlich, abgesehen jetzt mal von dem ganzen KI-Kram,
ich mag ihre Appearance.
Ich finde diese Art und dieses Terminal-artige Reden mit dieser Maschine,
also das ganze GUI ist wirklich nice.
Sie verbessern es eben auch Schritt für Schritt ja und ich würde auch sagen
noch Ivory war bei mir auch so ein großer Enabler der mir so den Einstieg in
Mastodon so ein bisschen,
einfacher gemacht hat ich würde mir jetzt fürs nächste Jahr wünschen Ivory für
Blue Sky das wäre noch geiler,
Und ja, ansonsten habe ich eigentlich auch gar nicht so viel,
was jetzt hier noch groß zu meinem Besteck dazugekommen ist.
Ja, ich muss sagen, dass ich vorhin, als ich über die Frage darüber nachgedacht
habe, am liebsten auch gesagt hätte, viele der Standard-Apps von Apple sind
inzwischen auf einem Niveau, wo ich sage, benutze ich einfach und fertig.
Also Mail oder der Kalender oder whatever.
Steht einem nicht mehr so viel im Weg. Ja, das stimmt.
Ich schreibe sogar irgendwie Briefe an irgendwelche Behörden einfach in TextEdit.
TextEdit, okay.
Hier Thema Ivory, was ich jetzt in den letzten Wochen intensiver wirklich genutzt
habe, haben wir schon zweimal hier erwähnt.
Open Vibe, womit ich halt gleichzeitig Mastodon, Blue Sky und Threads beschicken kann.
Weil ich schon merke, dass da jetzt auch so für meine Zusammenhänge einfach
drei sehr unterschiedliche Zielgruppen sich zusammenrotten.
Und wenn man eben sagt, man will ihm dann doch auch mehrere Zielgruppen bespielen,
ist das nach wie vor ein echt gutes Werkzeug.
Also zeigt das mal euren Social Media Abteilungen, wenn die immer rumnölen,
so viel Arbeit und dann muss ich immer so viel unterschiedliche Software und
alles so kompliziert und so.
Naja, so einfach ist es ja auch nicht, dass man einmal schreibt und das überall hinschicken kann.
Also wenn man jetzt nur Text macht, ja, aber wenn du Leute erwähnst,
dann willst du ja die richtigen Accounts haben.
Aber das löst das auf. Das heißt also, wenn die Leute auch auf mehreren Plattformen
unterwegs sind und dort dasselbe Handle haben, dann ist das Composer-Fenster
so, dass du nach Dienst aufgeschlüsselt bekommst, okay, meinst du jetzt den oder den?
Das kannst du dann auswählen.
Und dann wird es quasi pro Dienstziel genau der richtige Account reingesetzt.
Aber das ist derzeit noch alles nicht iPad und nicht Macintosh tauglich so richtig.
Das funktioniert immer alles. Das gilt im Übrigen auch für Blue Sky,
finde ich ganz furchtbar, dass das nur so eine iPhone-Anwendung ist,
also nur so eine Smartphone-Anwendung ist.
Leute, baut mehr Mac-Apps. Mac-Apps sind die Krönung des UX.
Baut sie jetzt selber mit Körse.
Genau. Trotz Swift ordentliche... Wieso trotz Swift?
Also Swift ist ein deutlicher Vorteil über Objective-C.
Meinst du? Ja.
Und Blue Sky hat immerhin jetzt ein vernünftiges Weltkonten.
Ich weiß, da gibt es Leute, die sehen das genau andersrum, aber die sind meiner
Meinung nach in der Unterzahl.
Okay, dann können wir die Frage mal jetzt als beantwortet ansehen.
Haben wir noch eine Frage, die wir hier beantworten wollen.
Das ist alles so random hier.
Was macht die Ratte im Garten?
Nicht viel. Also die letzte Ratte war im November letztes Jahr.
Die ging da in die Falle und dann hatte es geschneit und dann war mir das alles
zu kalt und dann dachte ich, ich kümmere mich um die Ratte später.
Und am nächsten Tag gab es nicht mehr viel zu kümmern.
Und dann seitdem habe ich auch keine Ratte mehr gesehen.
So, das spricht mich natürlich sehr an. Was habt ihr für Wasserkocher?
Und gibt es ja auch High-End-Geräte, die man haben will?
Ernst gemeint, ganz echt.
So, ich habe einen High-End-Wasserkocher, aber ihr könnt ja erstmal sagen,
was ihr habt. Ich suche mal so lange, wie man eigentlich heißt.
Ich habe einen Standard-Wasserkocher.
Also, zu High-End-Wasserkochern kann ich erstmal nur feststellen,
die kochen auch nur mit Wasser.
Alter das muss man schon mal wissen,
die kochen.
Auch nur Wasser.
High End Wasserkocher also was ist denn deine Vorstellung von High End in dem
Zusammenhang was ist denn sozusagen das erste Feature was jeder Wasserkocher
haben muss um irgendwie in die High End Kategorie zu kommen ich würde mal behaupten
ich behaupte du wirst irgendwas sagen was nicht meinem Primärcreme Theorem entspricht.
Temperaturvorgabe.
Grüner Tee bei 60 Grad.
Das ist das einzige Feature, was ein Wasserkocher braucht. Du willst nicht nur
kochen, sondern du möchtest es auch auf 90 Grad stellen können.
Du möchtest es auf 60 Grad stellen können. Das muss ein Wasserkocher können.
Keine blauen LEDs, würde ich sagen.
Naja, okay. Also das ist, sagen wir mal, so ein Medium-Range-Feature.
High-End ist ja wohl was anderes.
So, und das, was ich halt habe, ist der hier. KitchenAid aus der Artisan Wasserkocher.
1,5 Liter. Das heißt also, kein ganz kleiner.
Ruf mal auf den Link, wie schön das Viech nämlich aussieht. Also KitchenAid,
das sind ja die, die so dieses Standard-Küchenrühr-Teil machen.
Und das ist jetzt der korrespondierende Wasserkocher dazu.
Das ist wundervolles, so 50er, 60er Industriedesign USA.
So ein bisschen Art Deco mit so einer schönen, analogen Temperaturanzahl gehoben.
Gott, das ist ein hässliches Teil.
Das ist ganz schlimm. Da wollen die da 180 Euro für haben. Das ist schon runtergesetzt.
180 Euro für den Wasserkonfer. Aber hassen sie doch alle.
So und unten hast du halt diesen schönen Schieberegler, wo du genau deine Zieltemperatur halt einst.
Ach Gott.
Vielleicht ist es Perlen vor die Säue, aber vielleicht ist es auch Säue vor
die Perlen. Ich weiß es nicht.
Du kannst ordentlich rausschütten. Guck dir da vorne diesen Pinuppel an.
Ein Pluspunkt gibt es von mir einen. Für kein digitales Tasteninterface mit
Display, wo man die Temperatur einstellt und, weil die Einfachheit eines Wasserkochers
darf natürlich nicht verloren gehen, wenn er High-End ist.
Wenn er High-End ist, darf er nicht kompliziert zu benutzen sein und das machen
die meisten Wasserkocher schon mal falsch und für mich das primäre High-End-Feature,
was ein Wasserkocher wirklich zu einem High-End-Wasserkocher macht,
ist, er ist leise und zwar immer, selbst wenn er kocht.
Okay.
Und das soll wie gehen? Der ist dann schallgedämpft.
Ist mir egal. Findet eine fucking Lösung, aber das ist das Hauptproblem von
Wasserkochern. Hier, Wasserkochern, mach es laut.
Ja, das liegt aber daran, dass Kochen das Wasser nun mal laut ist.
Ja, dann muss man es halt isolieren und irgendwie sich was einfallen lassen.
Das geht auf jeden Fall auch in leise.
Na gut.
Denk mal drüber nach.
Ja, ich verstehe deine Anforderung.
Ist aber schon auch eher so ein Randgruppenfeature, oder?
Ja, gut, High-End kann ja jeder definieren.
Früher gab es welche, die extra laut gefiebt haben. wenn das Wasser kochen.
Ach Gott.
Ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Keine Ahnung. Also meiner Meinung nach, was ein Wasserkocher auf jeden Fall
auch haben sollte, ist ein Sieb oder Gitter, das den anfallenden Kalk zurückhält.
Also ich meine, ich weiß ja nicht, wie es bei euch so ist, aber da,
wo ich in Berlin wohne, ist das Wasser relativ kalkhaltig und man will nicht
ständig die Kalkbröckchen irgendwie im Tee haben.
Deswegen muss da schon auch irgendwie ein Kalkbröckchen zurückhaltendes Sieb noch drin sein.
Haben aber auch die meisten relativ billigen Wasserkocher.
Also ich habe meinen aus irgendeinem Supermarkt getragen für 30 Euro und der
ist völlig in Ordnung. Also keine Ahnung.
Ich bin da jetzt etwas überfragt, wo man jetzt da noch High-End sein könnte.
Ich denke, das haben wir jetzt auch ausreichend diskutiert.
Also ich habe noch einen Wecktopf mit 30 Liter Inhalt, den könnte man auch als
High-End Wasserkocher bezeichnen, weil man kann damit auch 30 Liter Wasser kochen
und dann abzapfen, aber das ist so.
Das ist die Enterprise Edition.
Das ist die Enterprise Edition oder aber die Bierbraueinstiegsvariante.
Also ja.
Ja, der Rest sind so persönliche Fragen, finde ich irgendwie.
Das ist nichts, was man jetzt so metamäßig diskutieren kann.
Der Chat kann ja nochmal aktiv werden.
Ja, wir können auch einfach sagen, wir haben jetzt eine Sendung zusammen, oder?
Oder so. Weil so richtig Themen haben wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Und dann kommen wir nämlich zu euch.
Im nächsten Jahr. Das ist so ein bisschen der Plan.
Oder auf dem Kongress läuft man sich über den Weg.
Ja, aber da machen wir jetzt keine Freakshow, da werden wir keine Zeit für finden.
Nee, machen wir keine Sendung, aber ihr könnt natürlich, wenn ihr uns erkennt,
Hallo sagen.
Genau, Hallo oder auch Fragen stellen oder keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Antworten
liefern, Verbesserungsvorschläge, nehmen wir immer sehr gerne,
also ich zumindest sehr gerne entgegen.
Und ihr könnt uns die Fragen stellen, ob wir sie dann beantworten. Haben wir jetzt nicht.
Kommt im Sendezentrum vorbei, da werdet uns schon irgendwie treffen und wenn
nicht, dann kommen wir wahrscheinlich kurz danach.
Wir haben noch keinen Termin geplant, aber das wird der dann sehen.
Das machen wir dann, genau. Juti, dann können wir ja mal hier geschmeidig ein Outro einspielen,
und Und wünschen euch einen schönen Jahresabschluss, Weihnachten,
tollen Kongress oder Ferien oder was auch immer ihr so vorhabt.
Und bleibt uns treu.
Weil das nicht zu heftig ist.
Genau, weil das nicht zu heftig ist.
Am besten gar nicht.
Und ansonsten habt doch einfach mal Spaß und programmiert ein bisschen mittelkürzer. Bis bald. Ciao.